Hi, my name is Jessie.
嗨，我叫杰西。
I'm in the US.
我在美国。
I'm 22.
我22岁。
I've been watching how I met your mother since I was 9.
我从9岁起就开始看《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
My loved ones would probably say that I'm weird about the show and I am.
我爱的人可能会说我对这部剧有点痴迷，确实如此。
My family moved a lot when I was young and I watched the show again and again and again and again and the colors of him and the characters and the vernacular.
我小时候家里经常搬迁，我一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地看这部剧，看他们的肤色、角色和当地的方言。
The apartment and the booth all constitute a very real and very consistent location in my mind and body.
那间公寓和卡座在我的脑海和身体里构成了一个非常真实且前后一致的地方。
when I don't have another one of those.
当我没有其他这样的地方时。
I'm trans, and I'm not gonna say that Hemium was a razor show that uplifts trans people, but I will say that every time I've watched the world shift against me, I found myself coming home to this show again, and again, and again, and again.
我是跨性别者，我不是说《老爸老妈浪漫史》是一部极力赞美跨性别者的剧，但我得说，每当我看到这个世界对我的态度发生转变时，我发现自己总是忍不住一次又一次、一次又一次地回到这部剧里寻找家的感觉。
I'm alone, I'll be soon, in New York City When I see you, please permit me to tell you everything in New York City.
我孤身一人，很快就会在纽约市，当我看到你时，请允许我在纽约市告诉你一切。
Thank you so much for that note, Jesse, truly moving to me and Craig.
杰西，非常感谢你的留言，这对我来说和克雷格都真的非常触动。
Welcome to How We Made Your Mother, where we discuss the TV show, How I Met Your Mother, which I starred in from 2005 to 2018.
欢迎收听《我们是如何创造你老妈的》（How We Made Your Mother），在这里我们讨论电视剧《老爸老妈浪漫史》，我从2005年到2018年参演了这部剧。
Oh, 2014 as Ted Mosvie.
哦，是到2014年，饰演泰德·莫斯比。
Craig Thomas co-created the show with Carter Bays.
克雷格·托马斯与卡特·贝斯共同创作了这部剧。
He's my co-host, hi Craig.
他是我的联合主持人，嗨，克雷格。
Hey everybody, hey Joshy.
大家好，嗨，乔希。
Hey, we're joined by Alec Lev are intrepid.
嘿，加入我们的还有我们勇敢的亚历克·莱夫。
I don't even know what that word means, but you feel intrepid to me.
我甚至不知道这个词是什么意思，但你在我看来挺勇敢的。
Is that something you are?
这是你的特质吗？
And this is your star episode.
这是你的明星剧集。
This week, if any, I am intrepid.
这周，如果要说的话，我是勇敢的。
Yes.
是的。
He's intrepid.
他很勇敢。
Welcome, Alec Lev.
欢迎，亚历克·莱夫。
Thank you so much, Jesse, for that voice note.
杰西，非常感谢你的语音留言。
We're very moved by it.
我们对此深受感动。
Craig, what do you, what's that provoking you?
克雷格，你对此有何感想，这引发了你什么思考？
So much gratitude is what it is, the first thing it provokes.
首先是满满的感激之情，这是它引发的第一件事。
And then the desire to apologize a little bit.
然后是产生了一点道歉的冲动。
I'll start with the gratitude and get to the apology.
我从感激开始，然后再说到道歉。
The gratitude is that somebody like Jesse could watch the show and feel that connection to the show while also seeing certain jokes and moments in the show that were, I think, clunky and ignorant where we made jokes that were sort of flippant and I think offensive to the trans community in ways that at the time, 20 years ago, we were, we as a writing staff, Carter and I were not, not aware that we were doing.
感激的是，像杰西这样的人可以看这部剧，并感受到与这部剧的联系，同时也能看到剧中某些笑话和时刻，我认为它们显得有些生硬和无知，我们开了一些比较轻率的玩笑，我认为这在某种程度上冒犯了跨性别群体，而在当时，20年前，我们作为编剧团队，卡特和我，并没有意识到我们在这样做。
And it's, I think it's so important 20 years later, like part of looking back on this show is, you know, owning some of that stuff.
而且我认为，20年后的今天，这一切都非常重要，回顾这部剧的一部分工作，你知道，就是承认其中的一些问题。
The idea that we get a message from somebody like Jesse, and we hear the love of the show and also the honest reaction to some of those moments.
我们收到像杰西这样的人的信息，听到他们对这部剧的喜爱，以及对其中某些时刻的真实反应。
And I've heard we've heard this before from members of the trans community, all of whom deserve respect.
我听说过、我们也从跨性别群体的成员那里听到过这种声音，他们所有人都值得尊重。
And they don't need to turn on a comedy show and see jokes that that might be using terms that are offensive to them.
他们不需要打开喜剧节目，却看到可能使用了对他们带有侮辱性词汇的笑话。
And we did that a couple of times, very ignorantly, just like to say sorry to Jesse and to anybody else in the trans community out there who felt at all hurt or other or pushed away from the show.
而我们曾出于无知这样做了好几次，只想向杰西以及跨性别群体中任何曾感到被伤害、被边缘化或被这部剧推开的人说声对不起。
It is a show, you know, one of my favorite lines from How I Met Your Mother is, love is the best thing we do.
你知道，这部剧里我最喜欢的台词之一就是，爱是我们做过最好的事。
I think that's the beating heart of the show.
我认为那是这部剧跳动的心脏。
And we want everyone to feel loved and respected and welcomed into our little world here.
我们希望每个人都能在这里感受到被爱、被尊重和被欢迎进入我们的小世界。
I'm so glad that Jesse was still welcome, still was part of it and felt inside of the show even as we made some mistakes and so I would just like to own those mistakes and say thanks.
我很高兴杰西仍然受到欢迎，依然是其中的一部分，并且即使在我们犯了一些错误的情况下，仍然能在剧中找到共鸣，所以我只想承认这些错误并表达谢意。
Yeah.
是的。
You know, it's interesting, it makes me reflect on if you're a member of any kind of marginalized community or minority, if you want to love cultural artifacts, there's a lot of stuff you're gonna have to kind of like skip over or jump over or swerve around, you know?
你知道，这很有趣，它让我反思，如果你是任何边缘化群体或少数群体的成员，如果你想热爱文化艺术品，你有很多东西不得不去选择忽略、跳过或绕开，你知道吗？
Like minority, you know, non-white people had to find themselves, even in our show, in white character stories, you know?
就像少数群体，你知道，非白人不得不去寻找自己的影子，甚至在我们的剧里，也是在白人角色的故事里，你知道吗？
And the beauty of the moment we're in, or maybe, I mean, they're certainly pushed back against this, which is not good at all, but that there are stories targeted more specifically to the people that they're meant for and it gives us an opportunity to watch, you know, a gay story and be like, ah, totally relate, totally moved by it, totally have felt all those things.
我们所处的这个时代的妙处在于，或者也许，我的意思是，当然也有对此的强烈反对，这绝对是不好的，但现在有一些故事是专门针对它们所面向的人群的，这让我们有机会去观看，你知道，一个男同性恋的故事，然后觉得，啊，完全能产生共鸣，完全被它打动，完全感受到过所有这些事情。
So I think in some ways, the more specific we can be, the more, it's the classic writing advice, right?
所以我觉得在某些方面，我们越具体，就越……这是经典的写作建议，对吧？
Like the more specific you are, the more universal you become.
就像你越具体，你就越具普遍性。
But I think that, you You know, like, I've always been struck by the fact that it is not white 20 and 30 somethings in urban centers that only love how I met your mother.
但我觉得，你知道，我一直对这样一个事实印象深刻：不仅仅是城市中心的20几岁和30几岁的白人才喜欢《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
That is not the fan, that is not the exclusive fan base.
那不是粉丝群体，那不是唯一的粉丝基础。
So it does transcend its character's demos.
所以它确实超越了其角色的受众画像。
Yeah, it does.
是的，确实如此。
And when we hear from people from other parts of life who still relate to the show, And it's the thing that makes me the happiest.
当我们听到来自生活其他地方、依然对这部剧产生共鸣的人的声音时，这是最让我开心的事情。
And when I realized that when there are moments that come up that I wish I could go back in a time machine and change, one of the reasons we're talking about this in addition to Jesse's wonderful message was that in the previous week's episode, which was Mary the Paralegal, there is a joke where Barney says a term that is derogatory towards the trans community that at the time, 20 years ago, I just think we didn't, we were too ignorant to know that And it felt that way.
当我意识到，当出现那些我希望能够坐时光机回去改变的时刻时，我们讨论这件事的原因之一，除了杰西那段精彩的留言之外，还有在上一周的剧集《律师助理玛丽》中，有一个笑话是巴尼说了一个对跨性别群体具有贬义的词，在当时20年前，我只是觉得我们太无知了，不知道这一点，所以才觉得没什么。
The sad part is it didn't even occur to anyone to flag it.
可悲的是，当时甚至没有人想到要去指出它。
No, no, no, nobody, and nobody flagged it, nobody thought twice about it, which is such a portrait of 20 years ago is a long time, and yet also look where we are as a society right now in 2025 and all the battles that are being fought for people's identity and to have respect and to be to not be marginalized, to just be able to be human.
不，不，不，没有人，没有人指出它，没有人对它产生第二次思考，这真实地描绘了20年前是一个多么久远的年代，然而再看看我们现在所处的2025年的社会，以及为了人们的身份认同、为了获得尊重、为了不被边缘化、为了仅仅能够作为一个真正的人而正在进行的所有斗争。
And I wish I could wave a magic wand and take anything out of the show that ever made anyone feel marginalized or outside of it.
我真希望能挥舞魔杖，从剧中删掉任何曾让任何人感到被边缘化或被排斥在外的内容。
Do you remember, Craig and happy, thank you more, please.
你还记得吗，克雷格，还有“快乐，谢谢，更多，拜托”。
There's a talk that my character has with Pablo Schreiber, where I say a writer told me once that every five years you realize what an asshole you were five years ago.
我的角色和巴勃罗·施瑞博尔有一场对话，我在其中说，一个作家曾告诉我，每隔五年你就会意识到自己五年前是个多么混蛋的人。
And it's just this continuing process of like, what an asshole I was five years ago.
这就像是一个持续不断的过程：我五年前真是个混蛋。
Four sets of those five years ago.
经历了四轮这样的“五年以前”。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，完全如此。
So I think about like the jokes we were making my freshman year of college in that freshman dorm.
所以我会想到，比如我在大学一年级和室友在宿舍里开的那些玩笑。
And like, there's not maybe one guy who I can think of would still be making those jokes, but no one else would be.
而且，可能没有一个我想得出的人还会开那些玩笑，但其他人绝对不会了。
And I think like, it's a good thing that comedy changes.
我认为喜剧发生改变是一件好事。
Like, I don't throw in with those comedians who are like, you can't say anything anymore.
我不赞同那些说“现在什么都不能说”的喜剧演员的观点。
It's like, no, you just gotta get better.
这就像是，不，你只是需要变得更好。
You just gotta get better.
你只是需要变得更好。
I totally agree.
我完全同意。
So between year two and three of how much mother my son was born and he has an intellectual disability And health, multiple disabilities, health wise too.
所以在《老爸老妈浪漫史》第二季和第三季之间，我的儿子出生了，他有智力障碍，在健康方面也有多重残疾。
And the way that changed my world, the paradigm shift that that was for me, you know, this kind of privileged white guy grew up among islands, you know, Irish American, like I have fairly sheltered, college kind of opened my world so much more, but I think having Elliot, having my son is the thing that really kicked the door open to realizing what it feels like to be on the receiving end of dehumanization in terms that are derogatory towards people with disabilities, to have the, there's that great line that's like, having a child is to have your heart forever walk around outside your body.
这件事改变了我的世界，对我来说是一个范式的转变，你知道，像我这种特权白人小伙子成长于各种群体之中，你知道，爱尔兰裔美国人，我的生活相当受到保护，大学让我的世界大大开阔了，但我认为拥有埃利奥特、拥有我的儿子，才是真正把门一脚踢开的事情，让我真正体会到成为非人化对待对象的感受，那些针对残疾人的贬损言论，就像那句伟大的台词所说的：有一个孩子，就等于让你的心永远在你的身体之外四处走动。
And that is what parenthood feels like.
这就是为人父母的感觉。
And if that child happens to be a little more vulnerable, a little more fragile, it's just magnified, but I think all parenthood really feels that way.
如果那个孩子恰好更脆弱一些、更娇弱一些，这种感觉就会被放大，但我认为所有为人父母的感觉其实都是这样的。
And like, the way that people with disabilities are spoken about and joked about marginalized and dehumanized in some of our pop culture vernacular and some of our political discourse now too is horrifying.
并且，如今在我们的流行文化白话以及部分政治话语中，人们谈论残疾人和拿残疾人开玩笑、边缘化他们以及将他们非人化的方式，是令人毛骨悚然的。
And it's something that I didn't realize how horrifying it was until I was in that world until my heart was walking around outside my body.
在我进入那个世界之前，在我亲身经历这一切之前，在我心肝宝贝在体外四处游走之前，我并没有意识到它是多么令人毛骨悚然。
And that's what I've had 18 years of that now of that feeling.
我已经经历了18年这种感觉了。
And yeah, sorry, I'm getting choked up thinking about it.
是的，抱歉，一想到这我就哽咽了。
It just, it changes everything, right?
它就是，改变了一切，对吧？
It changes everything to be in that.
身处其中会改变一切。
And not just about the, you know, in a lot of ways, like marginalized people stand with other marginalized people because they know, right?
不仅仅是关于……在很多方面，边缘化群体会与其他人支持其他边缘化群体，因为他们懂得，对吧？
They have the experience.
他们有这样的经历。
So it didn't just give you the experience of like, oh, I don't want anyone to say these particular words.
所以它带给你的不仅仅是“哦，我不想让任何人说这些特定的词”这种体验。
It was like, no, let's not, let's get rid of dehumanizing language.
而是变成了，不，让我们不要这样，让我们摆脱非人化的语言。
Like, let's reconsider the whole lexicon, right?
就像，让我们重新审视整个词库，对吧？
Yeah, you can't ask, yeah, it has to be across every, it has to be all can all equal parts across every sort of marginalized type of person, like when you have, yeah, I just think it's my glimpse into how it feels to be marginalized or to be on the receiving end of language that is sort of dehumanizing or devaluing.
是的，你不能要求，是的，它必须贯彻到每一个层面，必须对所有各类边缘化人群一视同仁，就像当你拥有……是的，我只是认为这是我的一点管窥之见，去体会那种被边缘化或沦为非人化、贬低性语言接收者的感受。
And I hate that there's some moments like that on the show.
我讨厌剧中出现这样的一些时刻。
It certainly wasn't the intention, but I think it's really important to own those moments.
这当然不是初衷，但我认为承认这些时刻真的很重要。
And I think you don't know till you know.
而且我认为在经历之前你不会真正懂得。
I think you, and once that door is open, you kind of see things much more clearly.
我认为一旦那扇门打开了，你就会把事情看得很清楚。
And so whenever we hear about this, I'm always, my instinct is to immediately say, yeah, I get it.
所以每当我们听到这方面的反馈时，我的本能总是立刻说：是的，我懂。
I'm sorry because I think we've evolved and we've come a long way.
我很抱歉，因为我认为我们已经进化了，我们已经走了很长一段路。
I know Carter Bay is my co-creator of the show and one of my best friends.
我知道卡特·贝斯，我的剧集联合创作者也是我最好的朋友之一。
I know this matters to him so much.
我知道这对他是多么重要。
I know he feels this way and he would be echoing these words and feel the same way towards Jesse's message.
我知道他也是这么想的，他会对杰西的留言产生共鸣并抱有同样的感受。
And so I just want to include him in.
所以我想把他包含在内。
us.
我们。
And I wrote you this little day to sing to you in New York City.
我为你写了这首小曲，要在纽约市唱给你听。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
And now back to the show.
现在回到节目中。
Craig, you wrote such a beautiful piece.
克雷格，你写了一篇如此美丽的文章。
Was it in the LA Times?
是发表在《洛杉矶时报》上的吗？
Where did that piece run?
那篇文章是在哪里刊登的？
Oh, the Boston Globe.
哦，《波士顿环球报》。
Yeah.
对。
Oh, the Boston Globe.
哦，《波士顿环球报》。
Yeah.
对。
If you can seek this out, maybe Alec, we can put this in the show notes.
如果你能找到这篇报道，亚历克，也许我们可以把它放到节目简介里。
Craig's article.
克雷格的文章。
Yeah.
对。
It was called Hollywood and the R word.
它的标题是《好莱坞与那个以R开头的词》。
And it is about a derogatory term for people with intellectual disabilities.
文章是关于一个针对智力障碍人群的贬义词的。
And this is what I mean.
这就是我的意思。
I don't like the comedy defense of it either.
我也同样不喜欢用喜剧来为它辩解。
We can't make jokes anymore.
比如我们现在不能开玩笑了。
It's just a funny word.
这只是个有趣的词。
And certainly that's what it, I'm sure that's how we felt in the writer's room 20 years ago.
当然，20年前我们在编剧室里肯定也是这么想的。
And we're like, ah, it's just a funny word to put it.
当时我们会觉得，啊，放这个词进去挺好玩的。
And no, it's not.
但其实并不是。
It's not a funny word.
这不是一个有趣的词。
There's no defense of it.
这根本无可辩护。
Once it's a joke that can hurt someone, find another joke.
一旦这个笑话会伤害到别人，那就换个笑话吧。
If you realize you're making a joke that hurt someone and like, I think there's this other defense of this where people would say, that's what that character would say, right?
如果你意识到自己开的玩笑伤害了别人，而且我觉得还有另一种辩解，人们会说，那是那个角色会说的话，对吧？
Or that fits the story or that fits the theme so the character gets to talk like that.
或者这符合剧情，或者符合主题，所以那个角色就可以那样说话。
I'm not going to defend our use of a word like that because there's nothing important to that saying that word.
我不会为我们使用这样一个词辩护，因为说这个词并没有什么重要意义。
It's just a dumb, meaningless joke.
这只是一个愚蠢的、毫无意义的玩笑。
It's a throwaway joke.
这是一个可有可无的笑话。
It could be anything else.
换成什么都行。
If you take the 10,000 jokes Barney made in 208 episode and you take that one joke away, It's not like suddenly no one can understand Barney.
如果你把巴尼在208集里讲过的1万个笑话中抽走那一个笑话，并不至于让人突然就听不懂巴尼在说什么了。
Like he's not even sharp enough for me without that joke, right?
而且如果没有那个笑话，他给我的感觉甚至不会显得不够敏锐，对吧？
It is a very clear character.
这是一个非常鲜明的角色。
He doesn't need to make that joke.
他根本不需要讲那个笑话。
And so therefore that joke has no nutritional value.
因此，那个笑话没有任何营养价值。
That joke isn't satire.
那个笑话不是讽刺。
It's not particularly character defining.
它也不是特别具有塑造角色性格的作用。
It's not because of the episodes about that or that's how this group of people would talk.
并不是因为有关于这方面的剧集，或者这类人群本来就会这样说话。
I don't think it serves any purpose.
我认为它没有任何用处。
And I think when comedy people try to defend, let me, we have to be able to say every word.
我觉得当喜剧界的人试图辩解时，比如，我们必须有权说每一个字。
I think there should be intention and meaning behind the use of any term that could potentially offend somebody.
我认为在使用任何可能冒犯到别人的词汇时，背后都应该有其意图和意义。
I think there's art.
我觉得这里面包含着艺术。
You look back at Huckleberry Finn and Mark Twain, he was writing a certain way to capture a certain moment, a certain vernacular, judging it by modern day standards and not understanding the satire behind it.
回看《哈克贝利·费恩历险记》和马克·吐温，他当时的写作方式是为了捕捉某个特定时刻、某种特定的地方方言，如果用现代的标准去评判它，却不理解背后的讽刺意义。
That's something completely different.
那是完全不同的另一回事。
But I just think if there's no real value to it and you're just throwing it out there, it's the empty shock value.
但我只是觉得，如果它没有什么真正的价值，而你只是随口说出来，那就只是空洞的博眼球。
That wasn't your encounter's most tween-like moment.
那可不是你最像少年的时刻。
No, no, it's not.
不，不，不是的。
It's not satire.
这不是讽刺。
It's not for a reason.
它不是出于某种原因。
If it's not for a reason and you can't explain the reason it's there in an artful way, you certainly shouldn't be using it and maybe not even then.
如果它不是出于某种原因，而且你无法以一种艺术的方式解释它存在的原因，你当然就不应该使用它，甚至可能在任何情况下都不应该。
But yeah, it's just one of those things.
但是，是的，事情就是这样。
I think you have to own it and you have to evolve.
我觉得你必须勇于承担当年，并且必须不断进步。
There's a British comedian named David Bideal who wrote a really great book called Jews Don't Count.
有个英国喜剧演员叫大卫·巴迪尔，他写了一本非常棒的书叫《犹太人不算数》。
And he's just been writing and speaking a lot about anti-Semitism over the years.
这些年来，他一直在撰文并公开谈论反犹太主义。
And I saw this clip of something where he said, there's two jokes I used to tell, or that I have told.
我看到过他的一段视频片段，里面说他以前讲过，或者他曾经讲过两个笑话。
The first joke relies upon the kind of stereotype about Jews and money.
第一个笑话依赖于那种关于犹太人和金钱的刻板印象。
The second joke, which is actually quite funny, which I'll tell, which is a German, a French person and a Jewish guy are sitting on a bench, and it's a sweltering hot day.
第二个笑话其实挺好笑的，我也来讲讲：一个德国人、一个法国人和一个犹太人坐在一张长椅上，那天天气酷热难耐。
And the Frenchman says, he says, I'm tired.
法国人说，他说，我累了。
I'm thirsty.
我渴了。
I must have wine.
我必须喝葡萄酒。
The German says, I'm tired.
德国人说，我累了。
I'm thirsty.
我渴了。
I must have beer.
我必须喝啤酒。
The Jewish guy says, I'm tired.
犹太人说，我累了。
I'm thirsty.
我渴了。
I must have diabetes.
我得患上糖尿病。
The reason he says, I'm going to keep, I will still tell that joke is because no one's killed Jews over their hypochondriacal tendencies.
他说他之所以还会继续讲这个笑话，是因为没有人会因为犹太人的疑病倾向而杀害他们。
Right.
对吧。
But there have been, there's a long trail of blood over this idea that Jews control things and have all the money and all that, that pernicious stereotype.
但是，由于“犹太人控制一切、掌握所有财富”这种想法以及那种恶劣的刻板印象，历史上流下了长长的血路。
So it almost is like, you know, if you go into a marginalized community, they're joking about themselves, right, in ways that they are allowed to, that they are, you know, it's so different when, you know, when someone tells a Jewish joke, I'm always like, uh oh, you know, if they're not Jewish, even sometimes when they are.
所以这就好像，你知道的，如果你走进一个边缘化群体，他们会以自己被允许的方式拿自己开玩笑，你知道的，这太不一样了，当有人讲一个犹太笑话时，我总是会想，哦哦，你知道的，如果他们不是犹太人，甚至有时即使他们是犹太人也是如此。
But yeah, I think that there are stereotypes that are for the, they're fun and they're like, we can enjoy them, you know?
但是，是的，我认为有些刻板印象是供人娱乐的，它们很有趣，就像我们可以从中获得乐趣一样，你知道吗？
And there's other ones that people get killed over.
还有一些刻板印象是会引发流血冲突的。
And we have to be clear about where we're telling jokes from.
我们必须弄清楚我们讲笑话的立场和分寸在哪里。
Yes.
是的。
I think also what Craig said about intention that if the marginalized communities is making a joke at their own expense, it is a bonding exercise.
我也认为克雷格关于意图的说法很有道理，如果边缘化群体拿自己开玩笑，这是一种增进感情的凝聚方式。
That's not what it is when someone from outside the community is tearing someone down.
而当社区外的人试图贬低他人时，那就完全不是这么回事了。
I get into these tussles about the R word because, yeah, I'm 18 years into being the parent of a child with a disability.
我会卷入这些关于那个R打头词汇的争论中，因为，是的，作为一个残疾儿童的家长，我已经当了18年了。
And so I wrote that piece in the Boston Globe, for example, I have a novel coming out in November that's in part about this.
所以，比如我在《波士顿环球报》上写了那篇文章，我11月份将出版一部小说，部分内容也与此相关。
And people online, there are people who yell at me and say, like, no one cares about the R word anymore.
网络上的人，有些人会冲我大喊大叫，说，现在没有人会在乎那个R打头的词了。
It's been destigmatized.
它已经被去污名化了。
It doesn't hurt anybody.
它不会伤害任何人。
We should just be able to say it.
我们本来就应该可以随便说。
And of course, I know firsthand from talking to many people with Down syndrome, for talking my son who has Jacobson syndrome, they don't want to be called that word.
当然，我通过与许多唐氏综合症患者交谈，通过与我患有雅各布森综合症的儿子交谈，我亲身体会到，他们不想被那样称呼。
No one wants to be called that word.
没有人愿意被那样称呼。
It's not okay because you're using the word to call someone else stupid or that they have no value, you know, because you're essentially using a word that sort of originated in the disability community and now you're putting it as a totally negative word on something else.
这绝不是可以接受的，因为你是用这个词去骂别人愚蠢或者说他们毫无价值，你知道的，因为你本质上是使用了一个原本发源于残疾人群体的词，现在却把它变成了一个用来贬低其他事物的完全负面的词。
That doesn't make it okay.
这并不能让它变得合理。
Like, I know for a fact that it hurts people in the disability community.
就像，我很清楚它确实伤害了残疾群体中的人。
So when people come at me and say like, it's no big deal.
所以当人们跑来对我说这算不了什么大不了的事时。
It's like, no, it is a big deal.
我想说，不，这绝对是一件大事。
I I know for absolute fact that it hurts people in that community and they don't want to hear that.
我千真万确地知道它伤害了这个群体中的人，他们根本不想听到这个词。
It also goes to the fact that the people in the community get to set the terms, right?
这也说明了一个事实，即该群体内部的人才有权设定界限和规则，对吧？
They sure do.
他们当然有。
They get to set the terms of the terms and if people in that community say that word is hurtful to us in the same way that there is a thing, sorry to make this about me, but the marginalized community of which I am a part is my religion is Judaism that I was born into and you know it gets enraging when we say that's anti-Semitic and people say no it's not you know non-Jews say no it's not and it's like why are we not allowed to set the terms of those terms you know this should be up to us.
他们有权定义这些词汇的定义，如果该群体的人说那个词对我们来说具有伤害性，就像有一件事——抱歉，这听起来像是在说我自己的事，但我所属的边缘化群体是犹太教，这是我生来就信仰的宗教，你知道的，当我们说那是反犹太主义时，人们却说不，这不是（非犹太人说不，这不是），这让人感到无比愤怒，我们就想：为什么我们不能自己来定义这些词汇的界限呢？这本该由我们说了算。
Yeah right so bring it back to Jesse if Jesse wants to our show and felt those moments to be painful and was, and was thinking, why, why, why does that joke have to be there?
是的，没错。所以回到杰西身上，如果杰西来看我们的节目，觉得那些时刻令人痛苦，并且在思考：为什么，为什么，为什么那个笑话一定要存在？
I, I love that.
我，我太赞同了。
That's how I feel when it's something I watch something and I catch the R word and there's no reason for it and it's just there for empty shock value.
每当我看到某些内容，听到那个R开头的词，而它又毫无必要地纯粹是为了博取空洞的眼球效果而出现时，我就是这种感受。
Also, those types of jokes where you're just name checking some shock value word, it's they're never the funniest jokes.
而且，那些只是为了抛出一个具有冲击力的词汇来博人眼球的笑话，从来都不是最好笑的笑话。
In fact, they're really never funny at all.
事实上，它们其实一点也不好笑。
And I think there's this weird defense sort of like in the sort of manist fear, like, like, like podcasty world of like, and a lot of stand up comedy now where it's like, there's this illusion that those are funny, that that makes it a joke, to use a shocking word makes it a joke.
我觉得在那种带点大男子主义色彩、类似“兄弟会”风格的播客世界以及现在的很多单口喜剧中，有一种奇怪的辩护心态，就好像有一种错觉，认为那些东西很好笑，使用一个具有冲击力的词就能让它变成一个笑话。
And it just doesn't.
但事实并非如此。
It's not clever, it's not surprising, there's no art, there's not an artful way of using it.
它既不精明，也不出人意料，毫无艺术性可言，也谈不上有什么艺术性的使用方式。
And if Jesse watched our show and felt those moments to be othering and painful, and yet, saw the beauty and the comedy and the heart in the show and stuck with the show, I would argue that Jesse has given us the greatest gift we could ask for, which is looking past some mistakes and seeing kind of the beating heart that beneath those mistakes, accepting our flaws and saying, this is still my show, this is still my place, and I just want to thank Jesse for finding that and fighting through that because I've had moments where I've had to sort of, and again, we keep on using our own ways into this, but where I've had to sort of look past certain things that feel ableist or wrong to me and still realize I love something about this piece of art anyway.
如果杰西观看了我们的节目，觉得那些时刻充满了排他感和痛苦，然而，却依然看到了节目中的美丽、喜剧效果和温情，并坚持看下来，我认为杰西给了我们所能要求的最好的礼物——那就是忽略一些错误，看到那些错误背后的跳动的心脏，包容我们的缺点并说道：这依然是我的节目，这依然是我的精神家园。我只想感谢杰西发现了这一点并坚持了下来，因为我也曾有过这样的时刻，我不得不——再次声明，我们一直在用自己的方式来理解这一点——不得不去忽略某些让我觉得带有歧视残疾人色彩或错误的东西，却依然意识到我无论如何还是热爱这件艺术品的某个部分。
And I'm going to find, I'm going to remember that I I love something about this and try to get past that.
并且我会去寻找，我会记住我是热爱这个作品的某一部分，并努力跨过那些瑕疵。
And I know it's not easy always.
我知道这并不总是那么容易。
So I thank you for doing that and anybody else who's stuck with us through those mistakes.
所以我感谢你这样做，也感谢所有在这些错误中一直陪伴我们、不离不弃的每一个人。
It's a gift, it's grace that you're giving us.
这是你送给我们的一份礼物，是你的恩典。
Well, that was beautiful, Craig.
嗯，那太美妙了，克雷格。
Thank you for sharing all that.
谢谢你分享这一切。
And thank you again to Jesse.
也要再次感谢杰西。
Jesse's message was a beautiful gift.
杰西的信息是一份美好的礼物。
Thank you.
谢谢你。
Yeah.
是啊。
Well, let's talk about this week's episode, Best Prom Ever, yes?
好了，我们来聊聊本周的剧集，也就是《史上最棒的舞会》，对吧？
Yeah, yes.
对，没错。
Yeah.
是啊。
Now we got to the star of the show.
现在我们要说到节目的明星了。
Alec, hold on.
亚历克，等一下。
Alec, hold on Alec.
亚历克，等一下，亚历克。
I can see him.
我看到他了。
Come on.
来吧。
Trumpin' at the bit.
迫不及待了。
When did this episode air?
这一集是什么时候播出的？
What date was this?
具体是什么日期？
I've got it in May 1st, 2006.
我查到了，是2006年5月1日。
Where your life changed.
你人生改变的那天。
This is the demarcation line in your life, right?
这是你人生的分水岭，对吧？
The before and after.
之前和之后。
There's before and after.
分成了之前和之后。
Yeah.
是啊。
like it was your last day of just anonymity.
就像那是你还能默默无闻的最后一天。
Yeah.
是啊。
Everyone calls me Todd when I walk down the street.
我走在街上时，每个人都叫我托德。
It's so annoying.
太烦人了。
How annoying it is.
真的很烦人。
Do you get it?
你懂吗？
It's very similar to what I have to do.
这跟我现在的情况非常像。
Very similar and it used to be that people would actually talk to me now.
非常像，以前人们还会跟我聊天，现在。
They just want to take pictures with me.
他们只想跟我合影。
It's so weird if I get behind them.
如果我走到他们后面，会觉得好奇怪。
Yeah, you're just like an image to them.
对，在他们眼里你只是个影像。
It's yeah, you feel very objectified.
对，你会觉得自己被物件化了。
Let's explain this.
让我们解释一下。
Alex in the episode.
亚历克在这集里。
Alec is in the episode.
亚历克演了这一集。
Alec plays Todd of Todd and Valerie fame, running to get the Von Smoot House, his van Smoot House.
亚历克饰演以“托德与瓦莱丽”闻名的托德，一路狂奔去抢冯·斯穆特故居，他的冯·斯穆特故居。
Craig, real quick, summarize this episode for us.
克雷格，快点，给我们总结一下这一集。
Written by Ira Ungerlater, who also appears in the episode.
由艾拉·昂格莱特编剧，他也在剧中客串了。
One of the great writer, one of the great writer's room names, by the way.
顺便说一句，这也是编剧室里最棒的名字之一。
Ira Ungerlater.
艾拉·昂格莱特。
Yeah, it's a great writer name.
对，真是个好听的编剧名字。
He's really the star cameo of this episode.
他确实是这集里的客串明星。
He's really the one that sticks in my head more than any other cameo.
比起其他任何客串，他才是最让我印象深刻的那一个。
No, okay, so this episode is Marshall and Lily in a frenzied battle to acquire the wedding venue they want in a fearsome chase.
好吧，这一集讲的是马修和莉莉为了争夺他们想要的婚礼场地，展开了一场疯狂的激烈追逐战。
We open on a chase scene, Marshall and Lily versus Alec Lev and, what's her name, I forget, your talk.
开场就是一场追逐戏，马修和莉莉对阵亚历克·莱夫，还有那个叫什么来着，我忘了，你的搭档。
Valerie.
瓦莱丽。
Yeah.
对。
Anyway, so they're in a battle to get that end to secure that venue.
总之，他们为了拿下那个场地展开了争夺。
They get that venue and then they realize they also need to land a wedding band and the wedding band they want.
他们拿下了场地，然后意识到他们还需要一支婚礼乐队，而那是他们想要的乐队。
They want to see live.
他们想看现场演出。
So they have to go to a high school prom to see that band and decide if they want to fully hire this band and by going to the prom it unlocks some of Lily's past and her memories and some things she's kind of feeling about her past and getting married now and sort of what her journey is.
所以他们不得不去参加一个高中舞会来看这支乐队，并决定是否正式雇佣他们；通过去参加舞会，这也唤醒了莉莉的一些过去和记忆，以及她对自己的过去、现在即将结婚的一些感悟，还有她的一段心路历程。
So do you know how they say that Tom Cruise is the best runner in cinema?
你知道人们常说汤姆·克鲁斯是电影界最会跑步的人吗？
Do you think that Alec Lev is the best or one of the top three runners in television?
你觉得亚历克·莱夫是电视界最会跑步的人，或者能排进前三吗？
By the way, it's shot out of a can in that run.
顺便说一句，那场跑步拍得就像打了鸡血一样。
The episode begins.
剧集刚开场。
I mean, it really...
我的意思是，真的……
He wants that house.
他太想要那栋房子了。
He wants that house for the wedding.
他为了婚礼想要那栋房子。
It's Todd here with us today.
托德今天和我们在一起。
I'm going to do the James Lipton thing.
我要模仿一下詹姆斯·利普顿。
It's Todd here with us today.
托德今天和我们在一起。
Can we talk to Todd?
我们能和托德聊聊吗？
Hello, Craig, Josh, let me ask you because it's not in the episode, and Craig, I assume you know the answer to this, and I assume I know the answer to this.
嘿，克雷格，乔什，我问你们个问题，因为剧里没演，克雷格，我猜你知道答案，我也猜我知道答案。
Do you know what the phrase best prom ever comes from, Josh Radner?
乔什·拉德纳，你知道“史上最棒的舞会”这个短语是从哪里来的吗？
Do you know where?
你知道出处吗？
Because it's not just that they went to the prom.
因为不只是因为他们去了舞会。
You tell me, Craig, if I'm getting at the right thing, Craig had a bit.
克雷格，你告诉我，我是不是说到了点子上，克雷格以前有个梗。
Craig always had a bit when he would do a little, it was a little dance thing.
克雷格以前经常玩一个梗，就是跳一段小舞蹈。
It was like this, the classic side by side, your hands are on the other shoulders.
就像这样，经典的双手搭在对方肩膀上的动作。
And Craig would always say, this is the best prom ever.
然后克雷格总是会说：“这是最棒的舞会。”
That's right.
没错。
You'd start slow dancing with people.
然后你就会开始和别人跳慢舞。
Yeah.
是啊。
What situation would it be?
那会在什么情况下发生？
I wouldn't.
我不会。
I don't know.
我不知道。
I can't.
我不行。
That is a deep cut.
那可真是个冷门老梗。
真是个冷门老梗。
Craig Thomas reference.
克雷格·托马斯的梗。
Thank you, Alec.
谢谢你，亚历克。
I feel very seeing right now.
我现在觉得自己被理解了。
Maybe it was from that.
也许就是从那来的吧。
I think it's all the way back to college.
我觉得可以追溯到大学的时候。
You did the fake arms and best prom ever I think when we were bored and nothing no one anything to say I would just start doing it and said that's So yeah, so you and Carter asked me if I would do this and the first story I have is that as a as a as a What is that called?
我觉得当我们无聊、大家都没话可说的时候，你就会做出假胳膊的动作并说“史上最棒的舞会”，所以我……所以你和卡特问我愿不愿意做这个，我的第一个故事是，作为一个……那叫什么来着？
I'm a I'm not I'm not a star necessarily what would you call them?
我是个...我不是...我算不上什么明星，你们管这叫什么？
I was a day player right?
我以前是个日薪演员，对吧？
I think that we day player.
我觉得我们就是日薪演员。
Yeah, it's a runner.
对，就是个跑龙套的。
I got day run I was a day runner, and there's a certain rate for a day runner.
我拿的是日薪跑龙套的，跑龙套的有一种固定的片酬标准。
And miraculously, you had to split those two scenes onto two different days, one running down the street day and one elevator day.
神奇的是，你得把那两场戏拆到两天拍，一天拍街上狂奔，一天拍电梯。
So A, I got paid for two days.
所以第一，我拿了两天的钱。
So I thank you very much.
所以我非常感谢。
I thank Michael Stade for the scheduling of that.
我要感谢迈克尔·斯泰德（Michael Stade）对档期的安排。
You know, this is something that I think this is just this is just inside baseball stuff.
你知道的，我觉得这纯粹是行业内部的幕后消息。
People don't understand that locations are kind of everything in terms of shooting and and scheduling and making the thing.
人们不明白，就拍摄、档期和制作而言，外景场地几乎就是一切。
So when you're watching Alec, Todd and Valerie run down the street, try to beat Lillian Marshall and then right cut to the elevator.
所以当你看到亚历克、托德和瓦莱丽在街上跑，试图甩开莉莲·马歇尔，然后直接切到电梯。
The magic of it is they stitch that together, but that's two separate days.
它的神奇之处在于他们把这些剪到了一起，但那是两天拍的。
The wardrobe keeps track of the outfits.
服装组会追踪服装。
They keep track of where the sweat was on the T-shirts.
他们甚至追踪T恤上汗水的位置。
You know, I mean, it's really that's what continuity is because you're, you know, you are almost never are you shooting something in order.
你知道的，我的意思是，这就是连贯性，因为你几乎从来都不是按顺序拍的。
It's always, you know, it's funny how I met your mother itself was non-linear, but the shooting of it was incredibly non-linear too.
总是这样，你看，《老爸老妈浪漫史》本身是非线性的，但拍摄过程也极其非线性。
It was, and I think we were the only re-watch podcast where the producer was also on the show at some point.
确实是，而且我想我们是唯一一个制作人也曾在剧中客串过的重温播客。
I would define anyone, I had to chat GPT, is that true?
我要向任何人发起挑战，我去问问ChatGPT，这是真的吗？
But anyway, so we have a real angle to work here, Alex.
不管怎样，我们在这里有个真正的切入点，亚历克。
So you were, it was your star moment.
所以你当时，那是你的高光时刻。
It was your star moment.
那是你的高光时刻。
The second story is that when I'm in the elevator, there was a painting outside the set of the elevator and I was looking at it.
第二个故事是，当我在电梯里时，电梯布景外面有一幅画，我在看着它。
And so we're doing our thing.
所以我们正在演我们的戏。
And Pam goes over the, or yell at her microphone.
然后帕姆走过来，或者对着麦克风大喊。
She yells, Alec, are you looking into the camera?
她大喊，亚历克，你在看镜头吗？
Cause I guess my eye line wasn't enough of off camera.
因为我猜我的视线偏离镜头的程度还不够。
I looked like I was very unprofessionally looking right into the camera.
我看起来很不专业地直接盯着镜头。
And then three, the much more important story is they're running on the street.
然后第三个，重要得多的故事是他们在街上奔跑。
So the Jason and I screaming at each other, we just, we just, we, we just improv that at the moment.
所以我和杰森互相大喊大叫，我们当时就是...我们就是...我们就是即兴发挥的。
That just happened right then and there.
那就在那个当下发生了。
That was funny.
挺搞笑的。
But then also I almost killed Alison a little bit.
但同时我也差点把艾莉森给弄伤了。
Wait.
等等。
So when we're running up those steps, I grab her arm and I pull her back and my intention was just slow her down a little, not pull Alice and Hannah can back down the flight of stairs.
所以在我们跑上那些台阶时，我抓住她的胳膊把她往回拉，我的本意只是让她慢一点，而不是把艾莉森·汉妮根从楼梯上拉下去。
This is why you have intimacy coordinators.
这就是为什么你们需要亲密行为协调员。
And that's why I was not invited back, I think.
我想这就是为什么我没有被再次邀请的原因。
Oh my God, we had a 10 episode arc plan for you and you were down after that one.
天哪，我们本来为你计划了十集的戏份，结果你拍完那一集就被拿下去了。
Yeah, but if you try to kill one of the series regulars, generally you don't get invited back.
对，但如果你试图谋杀剧中的常驻演员之一，通常你是不会被邀请回来的。
Generally, generally they don't hold you back.
通常，通常他们不会再留用你。
So I got the stairs, apologize previously for this moment.
所以我在楼梯那里，事先为这一刻道个歉。
Did she almost fall?
她差点摔倒吗？
Did she almost fall down the stairs?
她差点从楼梯上摔下来吗？
That's pulled back.
就是被拉回来那个。
It's not okay, but that's the take that's the take they chose right?
这不太对劲，但这就是他们选中的那个镜头，对吧？
It's in there Yeah, I don't think they let me do a second take they were like don't fucking let that guy in front of the camera again You know funny around looking in the camera.
就在里面。对，我觉得他们没让我拍第二条，他们当时就像是“别他妈再让那家伙出现在镜头前了”。你知道的，四处乱看还盯着镜头。
I remember I think first season Jason had a friend who worked with I think Don Johnson I think I'm remembering this correctly and Don Johnson said we got to go again a buzz the lens Which means I look directly into camera.
我记得好像第一季的时候，杰森有个朋友和...我觉得是唐·约翰逊合作过，我觉得我没记错，唐·约翰逊说：“我们得重来一次，镜头起雾了（buzz the lens）”，意思是我直接看着镜头了。
Yeah, and I'd never heard that that phrase before But it became a runner nine years, we'd say, sorry, I buzzed the lens, you know, I looked right into camera.
对，我以前从没听过这个短语，但它成了一个常态，九年来我们都会说：“对不起，我镜头起雾了”，你知道的，就是我直接看了镜头。
So that's what you were doing now, like you were buzzing the lens.
所以你当时就是在干这个，亚历克，你在让镜头起雾。
I thought that was the phrase like the universal Hollywood phrase, I buzzed the lens.
我以为这是一个短语，类似于好莱坞通用语，“我镜头起雾了”。
Is that it?
是这样吗？
It might be, but I didn't know it at the time.
可能是吧，但我当时不知道。
That was my first time I heard it, kind of like these dogs are barking.
那是头一次听到，有点像“这些狗在狂吠（these dogs are barking）”。
I'd never heard that before.
我以前从没听过这个。
Lillie said.
莉莉说的。
These dogs are barking.
这些狗在狂吠。
That's my Apple bag.
那是我的苹果包。
Unfortunately, I actually have no other.
不幸的是，我其实没有别的了。
That's it.
就这样。
That's the end of that story.
那个故事到此结束。
When you pull her arm out of her socket, you would think I should get injured on Buffy, not how I met your mother.
当你把她的胳膊从关节里拽出来时，你会觉得我应该在《吸血鬼猎人巴菲》里受伤，而不是在《老爸老妈浪漫史》里。
But you want to hear somehow she finds so many vampires and demons, but Alec Lev almost kills Alison Hennigan.
但你想听听吗，她怎么能找到那么多吸血鬼和恶魔，结果亚历克·莱夫差点弄死艾莉森·汉妮根。
Yeah.
对。
The behind the scenes video guy almost kills her.
那个幕后花絮视频工作者差点弄死她。
Also there is a moment around season eight or nine that there was a great reason to bring me back.
另外在第八季或第九季左右有个时刻，本来有个很好的理由让我回归。
I don't remember it now.
我现在记不起来了。
This would be such a better story if you remember it.
如果你能想起来，这个故事会好听得多。
It'll be good like three years from now when we get to that.
等我们三年后拍到那一集的时候再说吧，应该会挺好。
Okay.
好吧。
Well, okay.
好吧，好吧。
You have time.
你们还有时间。
Well, Todd and Valerie could have been another steward in Victoria, but because you tried to kill Ali, they had to make a very tough call.
好吧，托德和瓦莱丽本来可以成为维多利亚的另外两位管家，但因为你试图谋杀阿里，他们不得不做一个非常艰难的决定。
Yeah, you tried.
对，你试过。
You don't kill Alison Hennigan, man.
你不能谋杀艾莉森·汉妮根，伙计。
You don't do it.
你不能这么做。
Rule number one of show business.
演艺圈第一条铁律。
All right.
好吧。
Well, you were great.
你们演得真棒。
Where did Van Smoote House come from?
范·斯穆特大宅（Van Smoote House）是从哪儿来的？
Do you remember where that originated?
你还记得这个名字是怎么来的吗？
It's such a great name.
这名字真好听。
I think Van Smoote was like, sorry, are we done with me?
我觉得范·斯穆特就像是……抱歉，我的部分结束了吗？
Okay.
好吧。
We're done.
我们结束了。
It was great, it was fantastic, we bled that stone dry.
太棒了，这真是棒极了，我们把这个梗榨得一干二净。
It's good, but yeah, I think it was an actual name of like maybe Ira or somebody knew some wealthy family called that, I think.
挺好的，不过对，我觉得这是一个真实的名字，可能艾拉或者谁认识一个叫这个名字的富裕家庭吧。
I think it was based on, I'm sure we could look to some, I think it was like a real wealthy family name of some, from somewhere, but I can't remember.
我觉得它是基于...我确信我们可以查一下，我觉得这就像是某个地方某个真正富裕家庭的姓氏，但我记不清了。
Ah, I almost wanna look it up right now.
啊，我真想现在就去查一下。
It's all very old money, it's very funny.
这听起来很有老钱风，非常搞笑。
It's both funny and sounds kind of real.
既搞笑又听起来有那么点真实。
You know what's funny?
你知道什么很有趣吗？
I don't know who Todd and Valerie are, but it's funny, like when you're writing something, like I needed, I'm writing a script and I needed names of two kids, like a six year old and a four year old brother and sister.
我不知道托德和瓦莱丽是谁，但很有趣，就像你在写东西时，比如我需要...我正在写一个剧本，需要两个孩子的名字，一个六岁和一个四岁的兄妹。
And I just use Caleb and Addy because they're friends of mine who are married.
我直接用了Caleb和Addy，因为他们是我的好朋友，而且是一对夫妻。
I just think it's funny, like when you can always do little shout outs to your friends when you're writing something, I was just wondering if Todd and Valerie were friends of Iris or something.
我只是觉得很有趣，当你写东西时，总是可以向你的朋友们致敬，我只是在想托德和瓦莱丽是不是艾拉的朋友什么的。
Oh, I don't know.
哦，我不知道。
Of course, I just try to look up Van Smoot And it's like, oh, all how I met your mother references, but I think it was a real family.
当然，我刚才试着查了一下Van Smoot，结果出来的全是《老爸老妈浪漫史》的梗，但我觉得它确实是一个真实的家族姓氏。
Because it becomes the captain's last name, but we'll get there.
因为后来它成了船长的姓氏，不过我们到时候会聊到那儿。
But isn't it funny that it's, it fictionally buried the real bit of smoot because it really sure got so popular?
但你不觉得有趣吗？它在虚构中盖过了真正的范·斯穆特，因为这个梗实在太火了？
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, we took it over.
是的，我们接管了它。
And this is the episode where we meet Scooter, which is another notable appearance.
这一集里我们遇到了斯库特，这也是一个重要的客串。
We meet Scooter, who is played wonderfully by David Berka.
我们遇到了斯库特，他由大卫·伯卡（David Berka）精彩地饰演。
And that is the third, how much mother main cast about significant other, that's, yeah.
这是第三个，关于主角的另一半有多少，对，就是这样。
And so that, and he's great as Lily's high school boyfriend scooter.
而且他饰演莉莉的高中男友斯库特非常棒。
I would argue that the Lily scooter stuff and how it kind of informs Lily's feeling of cold feet that she's developing about her wedding, it's kind of the deepest, most important part of this episode.
我认为莉莉和斯库特的剧情，以及它如何展现莉莉对即将到来的婚礼产生临阵退缩的情绪，可以说是这一集中最深刻、最重要的一部分。
This episode's kind of like a fun one.
这一集其实挺有趣的。
They need these late 20s something to try to sneak into a high school prom.
他们需要这群快三十岁的人去尝试潜入高中舞会。
It's a fun, it's a fun bit.
这是一个很有趣的桥段。
kind of, you know, it's like a lighter episode, but there's this heavy undercurrent.
你知道的，这算是一集比较轻松的节目，但其中暗藏着一股沉重的潜流。
It's actually really interesting, you know, based on Lilly having felt suffocated by being too, in too serious of relationship in high school, deciding she wants to get to college and not do that and just be a little bit freer, a little bit like, you know, let's ease into being fully adult and fully committed.
其实真的很有趣，莉莉在高中时因为处于一段过于认真的感情中而感到窒息，于是决定上大学后不再那样，想更自由一点，稍微……你知道的，让我们慢慢过渡到完全成年和完全承担责任的状态。
And then of course, you know, day one at Wesley and she meets Marshall, which is this wonderful scene of seeing that in college and that me cute.
然后当然，在卫斯理大学的第一天，她遇到了马歇尔，那是大学里的一场美妙的相遇，也是那场浪漫邂逅。
I love how sweet that scene is, but also that it does play with the slate discordant note, right?
我喜欢那个场景有多甜蜜，但同时它也带有一点点不和谐的音符，对吧？
Because it's sort of, it's very sweet to see and it's also planting this little time bomb that's going to go off later in the season and a few episodes at the end of the season of Marshall and Lily running into some problems and Lily wondering if things are moving a little too fast in her life and if she's kind of breaking a promise that, you know, 17, 18 year old her made to herself by doing that.
因为看到这一幕非常温馨，它同时也埋下了一个定时炸弹，这个炸弹将在本季后期以及本季末的几集中引爆，讲述马歇尔和莉莉遇到了一些问题，莉莉开始怀疑自己的生活是不是进展得太快了，这样做是否违背了当年十七八岁的自己对自己的承诺。
And that's the deeper part of this.
而这才是这一集更深刻的部分。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you, knew who you're sitting, and now commercials.
还有这位老人，他肯定我，爱上了你，知道你坐在哪里，现在是广告时间。
Hey, I'm Carl Radke.
嘿，我是卡尔·拉德克（Carl Radke）。
You might know me from Bravo's Summer House, but on my podcast More Life, I get your favorite reality stars off the clock and into the conversations you don't usually get to hear.
你可能从 Bravo 电视台的《夏日山庄》（Summer House）中认识我，但在我的播客《更多生活》（More Life）中，我把你们最喜欢的真人秀明星带离工作状态，进入那些你们平时听不到的对话中。
The deep stuff, the vulnerable stuff, the uncomfortable stuff.
那些深刻的内容、脆弱的内容、让人感到不自在的内容。
I've sat down with Sierra Miller, Derinda Medley, Tom Schwartz, Lindsey Hubbard, and a whole lot more.
我曾与席亚拉·米勒（Ciara Miller）、多琳达·梅德利（Dorinda Medley）、汤姆·施瓦茨（Tom Schwartz）、林赛·哈伯德（Lindsay Hubbard）等许多人坐在一起畅聊。
We get into relationships growing up, the messy stuff, and everything that happens when the cameras aren't rolling.
我们探讨人际关系、成长经历、那些一团糟的事情，以及摄像机没拍到时发生的一切。
New episodes of More Life every week, listen wherever you get your podcasts or watch on YouTube.
每周都有《更多生活》的新节目，在各大播客平台收听或在 YouTube 上观看。
End of commercials, back to show.
广告结束，回到节目。
Well, I love that an episode, a more serious episode has these bursts of hilarity in them.
嗯，我很喜欢一集相对严肃的剧集中夹杂着这种爆笑的桥段。
Or conversely, you have these episodes that are largely comedy-driven that really, oh, hi, Nelson, like really shocks you, really shocks you almost with the gravitas of it.
或者反过来，那些原本以喜剧为主的剧集，真的——哦，嗨，纳尔逊——真的震撼到你，几乎以它的凝重感震撼了你。
But I also think it goes right into the vein of a pretty important theme of how I met your mother, which is how much do I honor or work on myself versus how much do I work on partnering?
但我也认为，这直接触及了《老爸老妈浪漫史》中一个非常重要的主题，那就是：我究竟该花多少精力去成就或完善自我，又该花多少精力去经营伴侣关系？
How much do I give up of myself within a partnership?
在亲密关系中，我又该放弃多少自我？
How much do I fight to hold on to my individuality or these other dreams?
我该如何争取保留我的个性或这些其他的梦想？
How much of I'm willing to sacrifice in regards to making a relationship work or looking for one?
为了维系一段感情或寻找伴侣，我愿意牺牲多少？
And I think that I thought this was so smart because Ted is the one who seems like he's an upheaval in the unknown, and from the get-go, Marshall and Lily are the settled ones.
我觉得这个设定非常聪明，因为泰德看起来一直在未知中颠沛流离，而从一开始，马歇尔和莉莉就是安定的一对。
the question of who they're going to be with is settled and they are settling with each other, that looks like, well, that was a done deal.
他们和谁在一起的问题已经尘埃落定，他们选择了彼此，看起来就像是一桩板上钉钉的事。
Like Robin says, everyone wants what you have, right?
正如罗宾所说，每个人都渴望拥有你们的生活，对吧？
And I thought it was, again, like the, what, how I make your mother does best, which is, it's not all one thing.
我又觉得，这正是《老爸老妈浪漫史》最擅长的，那就是：事情从来都不是单一的。
Nothing is ever one thing, you know, and I, and I think we mistrust, you know, it's almost like, like, like how a wife guys on, on social media get a lot of shit because they're like, they're always talking about how great their wife is and how great their marriage is.
没有任何事情是单纯的一面，你知道的，而且我觉得我们往往会心存怀疑，你知道的，这几乎就像，就像社交媒体上的那些模范丈夫经常挨骂一样，因为他们总是大谈特谈自己的妻子有多好，婚姻有多美满。
It's like it's always they're gonna have an affair like within, you're gonna get exposed within the year.
这就好像他们迟早会出轨一样，一年之内就会露馅。
Like I think we've learned to mistrust anything that does not paint with like more colors.
我觉得我们已经学会了不去信任任何色彩单一的事物。
Yeah, and there's this interesting switch that's happening where Ted and Raman are starting to have this detente and trouble is brewing from Marshall and Lily.
是的，这里发生了一个有趣的转变，泰德和罗宾开始走向缓和，而马歇尔和莉莉却开始出现麻烦。
And I, that's a very important kind of the pads crossing.
而且，这是一种非常重要的命运交错。
And it's kind of these two different wavelengths kind of crossing there.
这就像是两种不同的频率在那里交汇。
And yeah, nothing is all one thing, right?
是的，没有什么事情是完全单一的，对吧？
And even Lily says, I'm not having doubts about Marshall.
甚至连莉莉也说，我对马歇尔没有怀疑。
I'm having doubts about me.
我对我有怀疑。
And that's that idea of you're in your late 20s.
这就是那种你处于二十多岁末期的感觉。
And are you fully you yet?
你真的完全成为你自己了吗？
Has the cement dried on you?
你身上的水泥已经干透定型了吗？
Are you an adult yet?
你已经是个成年人了吗？
Are you the thing you thought you were going to be?
你成了你曾经以为你会成为的那种人了吗？
Is this the moment you should be most chasing your dream or most realizing like in real life, you don't do every single dream.
现在应该是你最该追逐梦想的时候，还是最该认清现实的时候——在现实生活中，并不是每一个梦想都能实现。
you know, you trade off, you trade one thing for another or you adjust your dream to include this other person and settling now with them.
你知道的，你会有所权衡，用一件事去换取另一件，或者调整你的梦想，把另一个人纳入其中，并与他们安定下来。
And she's really tried having that late 20s crisis that I think so many people have that I think we all probably have in some way.
她真的经历那种许多人都有的、二十多岁末期的危机，我觉得我们所有人可能都在某种程度上经历过。
I don't I really don't feel like I was a full grown up to like maybe yesterday morning.
直到差不多昨天早上，我才真的觉得自己完全成年了。
It's just like you're late 20s, you're still you're still so in progress, right?
就好像二十快到头的时候，你其实还是处在不断成长中，对吧？
I mean, you're in progress your whole life, hopefully.
我的意思是，希望你这一生都在不断成长。
But Lily's really having a moment here and it really plants a seed that's going to inform the end of the season in a huge way.
但莉莉在这里确实面临一个重要时刻，这也埋下了一个伏笔，将对本季的结局产生重大影响。
It's also a question about partnership.
这也是一个关于伴侣关系的问题。
I think there's two active forces in why we partner.
我认为我们结为伴侣有两个主要的推动力。
One, we meet the right person.
第一，我们遇到了对的人。
Two, it's the right time in our life to kind of do it.
第二，在我们的人生中，这个时候做这件事刚刚好。
And sometimes I feel, especially for people who I felt like my older sister married her college boyfriend, they didn't get together until their junior year, but she met him on the first day of like on the orientation bus, like the first year orientation bus.
有时候我觉得，特别是对于那些——我觉得我大姐嫁给了她的大学男友，他们直到大三才在一起，但她在第一天，比如在迎新大巴上就遇到他了，就像大一迎新大巴那样。
And they were friends for two years.
然后他们做了两年朋友。
And they've been married for years and years and years.
接着他们结婚很多很多年了。
And I don't know if she ever questioned that, but sometimes I think when you meet someone so young, you could be like right person wrong time.
我不知道她是否曾对此产生过疑问，但有时我觉得，当你这么年轻就遇到某个人时，你可能会觉得是对的人但时间不对。
Like it's too early, but this is the right person for me, then I think you have to engage in a process of, what's the word, like, co-growth?
就好像时间太早了，但如果这确实是对的人，那么我认为你必须经历一个过程，怎么说呢，类似于共同成长？
Like, you're growing with someone or alongside someone, and the hope is that you're growing somewhat directionally, similarly.
就像，你在和某个人一起成长，或者说并肩成长，而你希望你们的成长方向在某种程度上是相似的。
Because a lot of times you can, one, you know, I've heard it said that relationships where two people are committed to growth can work.
因为很多时候，其一，我听说过这样一种说法，两个人都有意愿成长的情感关系是能维系下去的。
Relationships where neither are committed to growth also can work, but a relationship where one person is committed to growing and the other is not will not work.
两个人都对成长不上心的关系也能维持，但是，如果一个人致力于成长而另一个人没有，这种关系就无法长久。
Yeah, that's that's right.
对，确实是这样。
Yeah, I think Lily is having a crisis of timing.
对，我觉得莉莉遇到的是时间上的危机。
She's not like she even says, I'm not having a crisis about the man.
她甚至不是在——正如她自己所说，我不是对这个人感到危机。
I'm having a crisis about time.
我对的是时间感到危机。
And I think like this is one of the things about aging.
我觉得这就是变老带来的感受之一。
Now, I didn't start feeling this until I was approaching forty, but there is a feeling, I think, when you age, especially as you as you enter into middle age, whereas, and this is something I was exploring in my movie liberal arts, but when you're in college, or high school, or even just out of college, everything feels possible.
好吧，我直到快四十岁时才开始有这种感觉，但随着年龄增长，特别是当你步入中年时，确实会有这样一种感觉——这也是我在我的电影《大学同学》里探讨过的主题——当你还在上大学、高中，或者刚毕业时，一切皆有可能。
Like, like, there's so many doors you could walk through, you know, you could pivot, you could be like, oh, I studied this, but I now want to do this.
就像，有那么多条路你可以选择，你知道的，你可以转变方向，你可以想，哦，我学的是这个，但我现在想做那个。
That that is still all kind of of allowed.
那种状态在当时基本上都是被允许的。
But by the time you hit or approaching 40, even sometimes your mid 30s, you've made choices that have real consequences to them, whether you had kids, you've lived a long time in a certain city, you've had a career that's taken you a certain amount of distance, might be really hard to leave and pivot into a new career.
但等你到了或者快到四十岁，甚至有时在三十岁中期，你做出的选择已经带有真正的后果了，无论你是生了孩子，在一个特定的城市住了很久，还是拥有了一段让你前行了相当距离的职业生涯，要离开并转向一条新的职业道路可能会非常艰难。
So I think that one of the things if you're going to talk about aging, and I think because how I met your mother ran for so long, we ended up dealing with aging, maybe even more specifically than you guys had set out to at the beginning.
所以我觉得，如果要谈论变老这件事，而且鉴于《老爸老妈浪漫史》播了那么久，我们最终探讨衰老这个话题，可能比你们一开始计划的还要具体得多。
But one of the big questions around aging in time is we don't have all the time in the world to live all the stories we want to live.
但关于衰老和时间的重大问题之一，就是我们没有无限的时间去经历我们想经历的所有故事。
We can't marry everyone we're attracted to or everyone we have some feeling of chemistry or connection with.
我们不可能和所有吸引我们的人结婚，也不可能和所有让我们产生化学反应或心电感应的人在一起。
That would be impossible.
那是不可能的。
We'd need multiple lifetimes.
我们需要好几辈子的时间。
So we have to make these choices and when you make choices, you naturally door snap shot slap, you know, a slam shot.
所以我们必须做出这些选择，而当你做出选择时，自然而然地，大门就会砰地关上，你知道的，砰然关上。
And there's a, it's, um, well, I don't know if I've talked about this, but, um, deer sugar, um, uh, Cheryl Strade, who is, if you haven't read, um, uh, tiny, beautiful things, have you read that book either of you?
而且有一种，它是，嗯，我不知道我有没有说过这个，但是，亲爱的糖果，嗯，切丽·斯特雷德，如果你还没读过，嗯，《微小的小事》，你们两个谁读过那本书吗？
It's incredible.
那书太棒了。
No, I haven't read it.
没有，我没读过。
Incredible.
太棒了。
But she, she wrote Wild and she also had this advice column called Deer Sugar.
但她，她写了《荒野》，她还主持过一个叫“亲爱的糖果”的咨询专栏。
And one of her most beautiful letters is about a guy, he's entering his late 30s, he's with a woman, they're both around the same age, they're both incredibly happy, they don't want to be with anyone else, they want to stay together, they don't know if they should have kids or not, they could make equally compelling arguments about having kids or not having kids.
她最美的信件之一是写给一个男人的，他快要到三十岁末期了，他和一个女人在一起，两人年龄相仿，都极其幸福，不想和别人在一起，想要长相厮守，但不知道该不该要孩子，对于要不要孩子他们都能说出同样充分的理由。
So they're really at this like fork in the road kind of crisis moment and they're like we have to decide.
所以他们真的处于这种十字路口的危机时刻，他们觉得必须做个决定。
And so the guy writes her and turns her and she said, you will make a choice and you'll be standing on the shore one day of looking out at the sea.
于是这个男人写信给她并向她倾诉，她回答说：你将做出一个选择，总有一天你会站在海岸边，望向大海。
And she calls it the ghost ship that didn't carry us.
她把这叫做“那艘没载着我们的幽灵船”。
Like often the distance they'll be this ship going by with your other life, the other choice that you didn't make, you know.
就像在远方，会有一艘船驶过，载着你的另一种生活，也就是你没有做出的那个选择，你知道的。
And you kind of just stand on the shore of your own choice and your own life.
而你只能站在属于你自己的选择和生活的海岸上。
And you have to salute that ship and you have to grieve on some level that you're not on that ship because there's heartbreak either way, you know?
你必须向那艘船致意，并且在某种程度上为自己不在那艘船上而感到悲伤，因为无论选哪条路都会心碎，你知道吗？
And I think that's something, there are concessions, there are trade-offs, every big decision we make is laced with a kind of grief and a kind of relief and a kind of celebration.
我觉得这就是生活，其中包含着妥协和权衡，我们做出的每一个重大决定都交织着某种悲伤、某种解脱和某种庆祝。
So it's just a, I think she's asking herself the biggest questions you could be asking.
所以这只是一种，我觉得她正在问自己你能问出的最重大问题。
They're appropriate questions.
这些都是很契合的问题。
Well, look, I mean, at the very beginning of this episode, we saw Lily almost die when Alec almost killed her.
你看，我是说，在这个剧集的开头，我们看到莉莉差点死掉，因为亚历克差点把她害死。
So her whole life flashed before her into a deep existential crisis.
所以她的一生在她眼前闪过，引发了一场深刻的存在主义危机。
I could have died because of Alec Love.
我居然因为亚历克·爱（Alec Love）差点死掉。
No, but I think one thing I like about Lily's journey in this one is like, she's been the rock for everybody.
不，不过我觉得莉莉在这集里的心路历程有一点很好，那就是，她一直是每个人的精神支柱。
You know what I mean?
你懂我的意思吗？
She's always everybody's rock.
她一直都是所有人的主心骨。
She's Marshall's rock.
她是马歇尔的主心骨。
She's the moral center of this group.
她是这个团队的道德核心。
We've seen her spend the whole season kind of being the moral grounding of this group.
我们看到她一整季都在某种程度上扮演着这个团队的道德基石。
I'm so struck by that on this rewatch.
这次重看让我对此印象深刻。
Really is the moral center of this group.
她确实是这个团队的道德核心。
She is the person that everyone looks to for gravity and the north star and the compass.
她就是所有人寻找的那种稳定力量、北极星和指南针。
And she and this one is realizing, I've been that for everybody for a long time.
然后她以及这个角色意识到：“我这么长时间以来一直是大家的依靠。”
I feel like I rushed into things a little more than I had planned when I broke up with my high school boyfriend who was trying to make me marry him and go to umpire school with him and live in Staten Island.
我觉得自己当初有点冲动，在跟高中男友分手时做决定比计划中快了点，那个男生当时想逼我跟他结婚、去上裁判学校，还要跟我一起住在史泰登岛。
Now I found this wonderful man, Marshall, who I do love, and is the right guy, but it feels all a little and fast forward and something about moving that wedding date up by many, many months and putting that piece, additional piece into fast forward, makes you realize like my whole 20s have been a little bit in fast forward.
现在我找到了这个绝佳的男人——马歇尔，我是真的很爱他，他也是对的人，但这一切感觉都有点像按了快进键，而且把婚礼日期提前了整整好几个月，把这个额外的决定也按下了快进键，这让你意识到——我整个二十几岁的人生其实都像是在按快进键。
I've always been the grounded one.
我一直都是那个最稳重的人。
When do I get to freak out?
那我什么时候才能崩溃一次呢？
And the answer is in the next episode.
答案就在下一集里。
And it's very human and Lily gets to be human and flawed in a way that I think really dimensionalizes her because no one is always the grounded gravitational center.
而且这非常人性化，莉莉终于有机会展现出人性以及不完美的一面，我觉得这让她的形象真正变得立体了，因为没有人能永远做那个沉稳的重力中心。
She's a human being too.
她也是个凡人。
Well, sometimes, we do this in our family, but I think we also do this in friend groups or are chosen or horizontal family.
嗯，有时我们在自己的家庭里会这样，但我认为我们在朋友圈或者我们选择的“水平家庭”里也是如此。
We fall into these roles.
我们会陷入这些固定的角色中。
And Lily, from the moment this show started, plays the role of the mother hen, the wise, the moral center, the moral compass.
而莉莉从这部剧一开始，就扮演着老母鸡的角色，扮演着那个睿智的、道德核心、道德指南针的角色。
she's the voice of reason often.
她经常是理智的声音。
And it's almost like she's rebelling against that role.
这感觉就像她正在对那个角色进行反叛。
Like, wait a minute, I actually don't know as much.
就好像是：“等等，其实我没懂那么多。”
And I think it's a great truth that we can often see so clearly other people's lives and what they need to do more than we can see our own.
我觉得这是一个很棒的真理：我们往往比看清自己更能看清别人的生活以及他们需要做什么。
We have a deep blind spot when it comes to ourselves.
在面对我们自己时，我们有着很深的盲区。
So I think she just reaches the end of, I've got it all figured out, I know.
所以我想她只是到了一个临界点，觉得自己“一切都想明白了，我都懂”。
And she just, it's almost like a, I don't know, it was like a time release capsule, this kind of crisis that she was just needing to have.
然后她就——这感觉就像是一个定时释放的胶囊，她正需要这样一场危机。
Yeah, and she gets to have, and she writes, and the way it's gonna throw a bomb into this whole group when they're moral center, when they're gravity, that's all holding them on the surface of the earth when she freaks out.
对，而且她确实迎来了这场危机，当莉莉情绪崩溃时，这就好比往整个团队中扔了一颗炸弹，因为她是他们的道德核心，她是他们的重力，把所有人紧紧吸附在地球表面。
There's a great moment in Jaws where they bring in the shark expert guy, and it's like, ah, good, we got the shark expert guy.
《大白鲨》里有一个非常精彩的桥段，他们把那个鲨鱼专家请了过来，心想：啊，太好了，我们有鲨鱼专家了。
He's the shark hunting expert.
他是鲨鱼猎捕专家。
He's gonna get the shark, and then he dies, and the shark gets him.
他会把鲨鱼抓住的。结果他死了，鲨鱼把他吃了。
It's like, fuck if the shark expert guy's gone, really fucked here.
这感觉就像是：操，如果鲨鱼专家都没了，那我们可真他妈完蛋了。
It's a little bit like Lily is about to sort of get eaten by like the late 20s shark here and kind of have her own freak out.
这有点像莉莉即将被二十几岁末期的“鲨鱼”吃掉，并经历她自己的崩溃。
And it's I like how it casts everybody a little bit a little bit out of our gravitational pull in season two.
而且我喜欢第二季里这种设定，它把每个人都稍微推出了我们的引力范围。
And that's what season two is about.
这就是第二季的主题。
I'm not I'm about I got one foot in kind of like astrology, whatever.
我并不是——我其实对星座之类的东西半信半疑。
And then the other foot's like I don't know.
另一半心里又觉得：我不知道。
But there is something called the Saturn Returns, which is this idea that from when in your 27 to 29, somewhere in there, the planets kind of realign of how they were roughly when you were born.
但确实有“土星回归”（Saturn Returns）这种说法，这个概念指的是当你在27到29岁左右的某个时候，行星的运行会重新对齐，大致回到你出生时的位置。
So people say in those years, 27 to 29, which is literally the first three seasons of how I met your mother, one of two things happens, either where you've been working and what you've been doing kind of gathers some steam and you feel some wind at your sails, like things start, things start really moving because you were on a path that You put pager dues, and doors start flying open, or you realize you've been on, your ladder's been parked up against the wrong wall, and you have to climb down and put it up against a wall that feels more aligned.
所以人们说在那几年里——也就是27岁到29岁，这正好是《老爸老妈浪漫史》的前三季——会发生两件事中的一件：要么是你一直以来的工作和努力开始积蓄势头，你会感到顺风顺水，事情开始真正向前发展，因为你一直走在正确的路上，各种大门纷纷为你敞开；要么你就会意识到自己一直以来都走错了路，你的梯子搭错了墙，你必须爬下来，把它重新搭在一面感觉更契合的墙上。
So it almost feels a lot of, you could, you could do, I'm sure someone has done this, you could do a kind of astrological breakdown of the Saturn returns of all these characters and what's going on for them.
所以感觉你可以——我相信肯定有人这么做过——你可以对所有这些角色的“土星回归”以及他们各自经历的事情做一个星象学层面的剖析。
It feels, it feels like it's, that, that, that feels, Stay tuned for our bonus episode where we just do that.
这感觉——这感觉——敬请收听我们的加更集，我们在那一集里就会专门做这个。
We'll be getting the astrologer on here to break that down.
我们会请占星师来节目里为我们详细解读。
Okay, well this, we are now at a beloved segment of the show, which we call questions and observations from a clinical psychologist who's never seen how I met a mother and also happens to be married to Josh.
好的，那么我们现在来到了节目的备受喜爱的环节，我们称之为“从未看过《老爸老妈浪漫史》的临床心理学家的提问与观察，她同时也是乔什的妻子”。
My favorite part of this episode was when Lily was exploring the road not taken, the life that was in certain ways sacrificed when she met Marshall and made the choice to be with him.
这一集我最喜欢的部分是，莉莉探索了“未选择的路”，也就是她遇到马歇尔并选择和他在一起时，在某种程度上牺牲掉的人生。
It reminds me of something I often say to patients, which is that with every choice, even the good ones, there's grief.
这让我想起我经常对病人们说的一句话：伴随着每一次选择，即使是好的选择，也会有悲伤。
Because whenever you say yes to one thing, you're also simultaneously saying no to all the other options.
因为每当你对一件事说“好”的时候，你同时也对所有其他的选项说“不”。
So I'm wondering if you can identify with that feeling, perhaps in your careers, and if so, when.
所以我很好奇你们是否能对这种感觉产生共鸣，也许是在你们的职业生涯中，如果有的话，是在什么时候？
I also wanna note that this was another episode sort of like belly full of turkey that highlighted that despite the show being about looking for love and the idealization of finding that person through Marshall and Lily's relationship, you wisely don't let us stay in that fantasy.
我还想指出，这就像是另一集类似于《满肚子的火鸡》的剧集，它凸显了尽管这部剧是关于寻找爱以及通过马歇尔和莉莉的关系来将“找到那个人”理想化，但你们很明智地没有让我们一直停留在那种幻想中。
For too long, you show us that people in good and strong relationships have their own struggles too, which I really appreciate.
你们没有持续太久，而是向我们展示了处于良好且牢固关系中的人也有他们自己的挣扎，我真的很欣赏这一点。
I love that point.
我很喜欢这个观点。
That is, yeah, that's what this was about.
就是这样，对，这就是这一集的内核。
That's what this episode was.
这就是这一集要表达的。
You know, Alec, I meant to talk to you about this, that we should probably play Jordana's questions a little earlier in the episode because she always points out, by the time you get to my question, you've covered a lot of what I've said.
你知道的，亚历克，我本来想跟你谈这个，我们或许应该在节目稍微早一点的时候播放乔丹娜的问题，因为她总是指出，等你们聊到我的问题时，你们已经把我要说的大部分内容都覆盖了。
So she, and it is true, but I will say this, she'll say to me, why are you taking all my stuff?
所以她——而且确实如此，但我得这么说，她会对我说：“你为什么抢我所有的梗？”
And I will be able to say to her, I hadn't heard your question because I hadn't listened to this one.
而我就可以对她说：“我根本没听过你的问题，因为我还没听这段录音呢。”
Yeah, no, I love the surprise of not hearing a prayer.
对，没错，我喜欢这种没听过提问的惊喜感。
Yeah, I think we're both, I think she even more eloquently than I did points up the fact that every choice is laced with grief and with sacrifice.
对，我觉得我们俩——我觉得她比我更口吐莲花、更精准地指出了这样一个事实：每一个选择都交织着悲伤与牺牲。
But I do think her second point is lovely and well-taken which is anytime, and again, we did touch on it a little bit, but anytime we idealize a relationship, what is it like, don't compare your insides to other people's outsides?
但我觉得她的第二个观点很棒，也非常中肯，那就是无论何时——再次强调，我们之前其实也稍微触及过这一点——每当我们把一段关系理想化时，那句话怎么说来着，“不要拿你看到的别人的表面生活来和你的内心情感作比较”？
Like if we really jumped into another relationship that we looked like, that we idealized or another career that we idealized, we would spend like five minutes and go, you know what, I'll take my own problems back.
就像如果我们真的盲目跳进另一段我们所羡慕的、被我们理想化的关系中，或者进入另一份我们所理想化的职业里，我们大概只会花个五分钟就会说：“你知道吗，我还是把自己的老问题拿回去吧。”
Like, we're not, it's so tempting to think someone has it better than we do.
就像我们不会——总觉得别人过得比我们好，这种想法太诱人了。
But everyone has their own battles they're fighting in no matter what they project out into the world.
但无论他们在世界上展现出怎样光鲜的外表，每个人都有属于他们自己的战斗要打。
Yeah, and yeah, this show, without saying too much about future seasons, like we play with the idea in this show about the idea of the one, right?
对，而且——对，这部剧在不过多剧透未来几季的前提下，我们在剧中探讨了“真命天子”这个概念，对吧？
The idea of like, idealizing any one thing, any one outcome, does that fit?
关于理想化任何单一事物、任何单一结局的想法，这真的合适吗？
Is that realistic, right?
这现实吗，对吧？
There's a lot of twists and turns to life.
生活有太多的曲折和转折。
Even when you find your person, there's a journey, right?
即使你找到了你的真爱，这也是一段旅程，对吧？
And life finds a way to challenge that and to make a different narrative than purely the one you had planned for yourself.
生活总会找到方法去挑战这一点，并创造出一个与你原本为自己纯粹规划好的剧本截然不同的故事。
And I think we see that here with Marshall and Lillian.
我想我们在马歇尔和莉莉身上看到了这一点。
And I think that's honest.
我认为这很真诚。
I think that's honest.
I think that's very real.
我认为这非常真实。
And I think Lily was due for this, right?
而且我觉得莉莉早就该经历这一遭了，对吧？
She's been a grownup, but the more we explore Lily later in series, she's been the grownup.
她一直表现得像个成年人，但随着我们在剧集中对莉莉进行更深入的挖掘，她一直都是那个成熟的大人。
She was kind of the grownup with her parents a little bit.
在面对她父母时，她多少有点像个大人。
She was the grownup with scooter.
在面对斯库特时，她是个大人。
She's grown up with Marshall.
她在马歇尔面前也是个成熟的大人。
And she needed a moment to not have to be under that level of gravity.
她需要一个时刻，不用再承受那种级别的重压。
And I think it's really interesting.
我觉得这真的很有意思。
These next couple of episodes are really interesting for Lily.
接下来的这几集对莉莉来说真的非常有趣。
There's some great Ted and Lily stuff coming up in the next one, Josh.
乔什，下一集里有一些泰德和莉莉的很棒的对手戏。
I think you guys were really great together in the next episode we'll talk about.
我觉得我们在接下来要讨论的那一集里，你们两个的合作真的很棒。
And yeah, I think challenging that idea of perfection and anyone's at the finish line.
而且，对，我觉得挑战那种完美主义的概念，以及“谁已经冲过终点线”的想法。
No one's at their finish line, right?
没有人冲过终点线，对吧？
You're always, there's all the life is one big marathon and you're not at the finish line really ever until the end of the end, end, end.
你一直在——生活是一场宏大的马拉松，直到生命的尽头、尽头、尽头，你才算真正到达终点。
And Marshall and Lily, they weren't done.
而马歇尔和莉莉，他们还没结束。
They weren't done.
他们还没结束。
Nothing was all the way solved yet.
一切都还没有完全解决。
You know, someone said something to me about parenting.
你知道的，有人曾跟我谈过育儿经。
They said, parenting is particularly difficult because just when you know how to parent a three month old, they're six-month-old.
他们说，育儿之所以特别困难，是因为正当你刚弄懂怎么照顾三个月的婴儿时，他们就六个月大了。
And just when you feel like you've got the hang of the one-year-old, they're three-year-old, three-years-old, which necessitates a whole other level of new information.
而正当你觉得自己摸清了带一岁小孩的门道时，他们三岁了，而三岁又需要一整套全新的知识储备。
And it almost feels like Marshall and Lily were really good at being college sweethearts.
这感觉就像马歇尔和莉莉很擅长做大学情侣。
And then they got really good at being boyfriend and girlfriend who lived together with Ted in New York City.
然后他们变得很擅长做和泰德一起在纽约市合租的男友和女友。
And then they had to adjust to being, and you saw Lily trying to adjust to that.
接着他们不得不适应——你看到莉莉试图去适应这一点。
having the ring and what that means, and maybe she wouldn't be flirting anymore.
戴上戒指意味着什么，也许她以后再也不能和别人调情了。
Guys wouldn't be approaching her.
男生们也不会再来搭讪她了。
Then, oh my God, we're getting married in two months, and that's just a cold plunge that just shocks her system.
然后，天呐，我们两个月后就要结婚了，这就像是一场冷水澡，彻底给她的系统来了个大冲击。
Yeah, and it really sets off like a little kind of ticking time bomb that takes, I really feel momentum at the end of this episode.
对，这真的像引发了一个小小的定时炸弹，让我在这一集的结尾真正感受到了情绪的推动力。
The two of them dancing to their song and it's both sweet and ominous was really cool.
他们两个伴随着自己的歌声跳舞，那种画面既甜蜜又透着不祥的预感，真的很酷。
I think in this otherwise very light feeling episode, them dancing to good feeling by the violent femmes.
我觉得在这一集原本非常轻松愉快的氛围中，他们随着暴力女性乐队（Violent Femmes）的《Good Feeling》翩翩起舞。
And there's some, there's kind of like, there's kind of jaw, to bring it back to Jaws again.
而且——为了再次把话题扯回《大白鲨》——
There's kind of like a little Jaws music by playing underneath it, like emotionally.
这就有点像在情感暗流中，隐约播放着《大白鲨》的主题音乐。
There's something I like, that's very interesting to watch.
我喜欢某些东西，看着非常有趣。
I really liked that at the end of this.
我很喜欢这集的结尾。
And it spins you into the end of the season.
它把你们带入了这一季的尾声。
It's also the perfect song from the perfect band because violent femmes, even their name, like there is discordant, you know, like violent femmes is like, they're like toe-tapping, fun band who are also like, they've got a darkness to them and a dissonance to them and even singing about good feeling.
这也是来自完美乐队的完美歌曲，因为暴力女性（Violent Femmes），甚至他们的名字，你知道的，就有一种不和谐感，你知道，就像暴力女性这支乐队，他们听起来像是那种让人想跟着轻叩脚趾、很有趣的乐队，但同时他们身上又有一种黑暗感和不协和音，甚至连在唱好心情时也是如此。
There's like these flat notes that feel like, you know, like, like, just like they won't quite let you have the good feeling, you know.
有那种听起来像是平音的音符，让你觉得，你知道的，就像是……就是不愿让你完全拥有那种好心情，你知道的。
Do you have any moments, Craig, in your life that you felt like you knew you made the right choice, but you also felt the sting of the sacrifice every moment.
克雷格，你的人生中有没有过这样的时刻：你觉得自己做了正确的选择，但每一刻你也都感受到了牺牲带来的刺痛感？
Probably a lot, probably a lot of them probably every moment, right?
可能有很多，可能有很多次，大概每个时刻都是吧？
I mean, yeah, I mean, it's such a tough one to answer.
我是说，对啊，这真的很难回答。
It's like, you sign up for things thinking you know what they are, right?
这就好比，你答应做一件事情时以为自己知道它是什么，对吧？
And then they turn out to be complicated beyond what you thought.
然后结果却发现它比你想象的要复杂得多。
And they're like, this wasn't exactly what I ordered up out of the catalog.
接着你会想：这可不是我从目录里点的那款商品啊。
And then you have to figure out how it fits anyway.
然后你只能想办法不管怎样先适应它。
And then any choice, you can't be haunted by that grass is always greener shit because you will never get anywhere.
而且在任何选择面前，你都不能被“草总是绿的”这种鬼话所纠缠，因为那样你将一事无成。
Most of the big decisions I've made feel like the right ones and also they're challenging.
我做过的大多数重大决定都觉得是正确的，但同时也充满挑战。
And they also have an adjustment period, you know, like when someone starts a new job or moves and they come to me kind of in there, scared, I say, give it four months, give it six months.
它们也需要一段适应期，你知道的，就像有人开始一份新工作或者搬家时，他们带着恐惧来找我，我会对他们说：给它四个月，给它六个月。
Like if you're deciding in the first couple of days, you will want to leave, you'll be convinced you made the wrong decision.
如果你在头几天就做决定，你会想离开，你会坚信自己做错了决定。
Like we have a metabolizing kind of grace.
就像我们需要有一种自我代谢式的宽容。
we have to give ourselves.
我们必须给自己这种宽容。
For me, I know that sometimes you get offered two jobs at once and you feel you got to decide.
对我来说，我知道有时你同时获得两份工作机会，你会觉得必须立刻做出抉择。
I have a couple of passes that haunt me a little bit because it's a sliding door.
我有几次错过的机会至今仍让我有些萦绕心头，因为那就像一扇滑动门。
It's like, well, what if I'd done that job instead of this one or what if I'd done that job instead of deciding to go away or do you know what I mean?
就像是，如果我选了那份工作而不是这一份会怎么样？或者如果我选了那份工作而不是决定离开或者别的什么，你知道我的意思吗？
Showbiz gives you a lot of those moments of second-guessing and self-reflection.
演艺圈会给你很多这种充满自我怀疑和反思的时刻。
Yeah.
对。
Hiring Alec Lev.
雇佣亚历克·莱夫（Alec Lev）。
I mean, I regret that.
我是说，我后悔过那个。
You almost killed Alison Hannigan.
你差点害死艾莉森·汉妮根（Alyson Hannigan）。
So it's, you know, it's, you know, it's, you look back and your hindsight's 2020.
所以，你知道的，这就是……你回过头看，事后诸葛亮总是最清醒的。
Also the many, many things that we haven't talked about about Alex that could give us pause.
还有很多很多我们没有聊到的关于亚历克的、能让我们犹豫不决的事情。
I'm kidding.
我开玩笑的。
Alex.
亚历克。
Take your time.
慢慢来。
You're interested.
你很有趣。
We love you.
我们爱你。
You're entrapped.
你被套牢了。
We love you.
我们爱你。
Can we run through a couple of things I found very funny?
我们能回顾一下我发现的几个非常搞笑的梗吗？
I loved, oh, it is on like former Soviet Republic of Azerbaijan.
我很喜欢，哦，就是“在前苏联加盟共和国阿塞拜疆”。
Such a weird line.
这台词太古怪了。
It's such a weird line.
I enjoy that.
我很喜欢这个。
Without you, that feels like a Craig Thomas line.
没有你，这感觉就像是一句克雷格·托马斯的台词。
I don't know.
我不知道。
I don't think that was me.
我觉得那不是我写的。
I think that might have been Ira.
我觉得那可能是艾拉（Ira）写的。
I think that might have been Ira Unger later.
我觉得那可能是后来的艾拉·昂格尔（Ira Unger）。
The writer of this episode who also played, he wrote for Friends.
这一集的编剧，他也曾为《老友记》担任过编剧。
He's a very funny guy.
他是个非常有趣的人。
One of a couple writers that wrote for Friends and Greg Mayland's being the other one that also wrote Pramish Mother and Ira plays the guy at the prom who sort of seems to work at the school who says to them and say, try and enter.
他是为《老友记》写过剧本的几位编剧之一，格雷格·梅尔兰德（Greg Malins）是另一个也写过《老友记》和《老爸老妈浪漫史》的人，而艾拉在剧中饰演了那个在舞会上、似乎在学校工作、对他们说“试着进去吧，你们显然是成年人，请离开这里”的那个人。
you're clearly adults, please leave here.
你们显然是成年人，请离开这里。
And that's Azaira.
那就是阿塞拜疆。
But I think that might have been his joke.
但我猜那可能是他的笑话。
I like when Barney was like, it's still really awkward.
我喜欢巴尼说“这还是真的很尴尬”。
Like there was something really funny about- That was funny.
就好像有什么东西真的很好笑——那个很好笑。
He understands social cues.
他懂社交暗示。
Like he absolutely understands it.
他绝对懂。
He just won't give in to it.
他只是不肯向它妥协。
Like he won't participate in the awkwardness but he'll call out the awkwardness.
就像他不会参与到尴尬中去，但他会把尴尬点出来。
And enjoy it.
并且乐在其中。
Hey, this is happening.
嘿，这正在发生呢。
This awkwardness is still happening.
这种尴尬现在还在继续。
Yeah, it's a Christmas morning.
对，就像圣诞节的早晨。
Um, what is a Marshall and maybe laugh when you said, look, they're all tuckered out.
呃，玛修说的什么话逗笑了你？当你说“看，他们都累垮了”。
Hey, that was really cute.
嘿，那真的很可爱。
Um, guilty of guilty on three counts of rocking.
呃，“犯有三项摇滚罪”。
Who said that?
谁说的那个？
Was that Marshall?
是玛修吗？
Yeah.
对。
That was funny.
那个挺好笑的。
Marshall talking about them talking about the 88.
玛修在谈论他们谈论“88乐队”（The 88）。
Who is the 88?
谁是88乐队？
Or who were real band?
或者说他们是真正的乐队吗？
I mean, he's a couple of their real songs in here and they did a great cover of, uh, violent femmes here.
我的意思是，这里面有他们的几首真歌，而且他们在这里对暴力女性乐队（Violent Femmes）有一首很棒的翻唱。
They're awesome.
他们太棒了。
We love those guys.
我们爱这群家伙。
They use their song, um, uh, you belong to me and Bellyfall Turkey too, which is a great end of that episode.
他们用了他们的歌，呃，《你属于我》（You Belong to Me）还有《土耳其狂欢节》（Belly Full of Turkey），那也是那一集非常棒的结尾。
It's a great use of an 88 song, so.
那是对88乐队歌曲的一次极佳运用，所以。
They were very, the 88 was kind of the, how I met in one of their season one house band.
他们非常……88乐队可以说是《老爸老妈浪漫史》第一季的御用驻场乐队。
Like they were really like a part of the first season.
他们真的很像是第一季的一部分。
I loved all the Bonzo, the John Bonham, like your cousin is John Bonham.
我喜欢所有关于邦佐（Bonzo）、约翰·博纳姆（John Bonham）的梗，比如“你表弟是约翰·博纳姆”。
It's like so weirdly specific and so again, but also like to me as a music fan, like being on a show that references the Led Zeppelin drummer, like, Bonzo.
这听起来太诡异地具体了，而且再次体现了，对我这样一个乐迷来说，能在一部向齐柏林飞艇乐队鼓手致敬的剧中……就像是，邦佐。
Bonzo.
邦佐。
But dude, that's my drum teacher.
但是老兄，那是我的架子鼓老师。
The whole way I know how to play drums is John Bonham.
我学会打鼓的全部方式就是通过约翰·博纳姆。
He was my, uh, from beyond the grave drum teacher and me and me.
他是我那来自阴间的架子鼓老师，还有我……
Oh, nice.
哦，不错。
I play along the Led Zeppelin two and four is basically how I learn drums.
我跟着《齐柏林飞艇 II》边打边练，这就是我学打鼓的基本方法。
Anyway, scooters, uh, longing to go to empire school is so funny and so specific.
不管怎样，斯科特（Scooter）渴望去裁判学校上学这事太搞笑了，也太具体了。
Like where did that come from and wanting to live on Staten Island?
这灵感是从哪来的？还有想住在史泰登岛（Staten Island）？
Like it's just such a specific dream.
这纯粹是一个极其具体的梦想。
think I might have pitched that one because I was just I think I've just the idea of there being an umpire school just stuck in my brain like it's just some something I've always been really funny that there's an umpire school.
我觉得这个点子可能是我提出来的，因为我只是……我觉得脑子里一直挥之不去“竟然有裁判学校”这种概念，就好像这纯粹是我一直觉得有裁判学校这事非常搞笑。
I don't know we just wanted Scooter to have a really weird obsession and the fact that he looked like Kurt Cobain but wanted to be an umpire was so weird and discordant and I can also like Kurt Cobain.
我不知道，我们只是想让斯科特有一种非常古怪的执念，而他长得像库尔特·柯本（Kurt Cobain）却想当个棒球裁判，这种设定太诡异、太不和谐了，而且我也能顺便致敬一下库尔特·柯本。
David Berg, very funny.
大卫·伯格（David Berg），非常搞笑。
I can look more like Kurt Cobain.
我能看起来更像库尔特·柯本。
It's so funny.
太搞笑了。
That was so funny.
那真的太搞笑了。
I don't think I think he could have that.
我觉得我不认为他能那样。
That's great, David's very funny.
太棒了，大卫非常搞笑。
I don't think he should have.
我不认为他应该那样。
He really looked a lot like Kurt Cobain.
他真的很像科特·柯本。
I also think it's funny to kind of invent your own colloquialism like disco.
我也觉得发明自己的俗语，比如“迪斯科”，挺好玩的。
Was it really funny bit?
真的是个好笑的梗吗？
Well, that's a, because it was in like 1996, we, that's a straight up whole fiction reference.
嗯，那是，因为那是在1996年左右，我们，那是一个彻头彻尾的《低俗小说》梗。
That's our boy, Quentin Tarantino, who we love and who is a how I met your mother fan, which delights us to no end.
那是我们的好兄弟昆汀·塔伦蒂诺，我们深爱着他，而且他还是个《老爸老妈浪漫史》的粉丝，这让我们高兴极了。
Cause there's a little moment in Pulp Fiction, which is obviously as mid nineties as it gets.
因为《低俗小说》里有一个小片段，那可以说是90年代中期最具代表性的了。
And where he, I think she's steering John Travolta to find where the bar is to harm self drink.
在那里他，我想她是引导约翰·特拉沃尔塔去找酒吧自己喝一杯。
While she's up getting ready and she's like, warm, warmer disco.
当她正准备出门时，她说，热，更热，迪斯科。
And just that idea that Uma Thurman says disco.
而乌玛·瑟曼说出“迪斯科”这个词的这个想法。
I think we just took that and said that Lily saw Pulp Fiction and started saying disco for a while.
我想我们只是采用了这一点，并认为莉莉看了《低俗小说》，然后有一段时间开始说“迪斯科”。
After seeing that's the backstory of why she says disco.
看过之后，这就是她为什么说“迪斯科”的背景故事。
Do you know what's funny?
你知道什么很有趣吗？
In that she actually has the Uma Thurman Pulp Fiction haircut.
在这部剧里，她实际上顶着乌玛·瑟曼在《低俗小说》里的发型。
She looks like Uma Thurman.
她看起来就像乌玛·瑟曼。
She has a Uma Thurman haircut.
她留着乌玛·瑟曼的发型。
So she says disco.
所以她说迪斯科。
That's why.
就是这样。
Yeah, that's it.
对，就是这样。
I like when Scooter says, we're going to be an umpire someday.
我喜欢斯科特说，我们总有一天会成为裁判。
We're going to no baseline.
我们要去没有底线的地方。
We're going to be an umpire.
我们要当裁判。
Yeah.
是啊。
Yeah, it's so funny when I think it's Marshall and Ted are talking to, I don't know who, but you've seen Barney climb through that window and then security.
对，太好笑了，我想是马歇尔和泰德在和谁说话，我不知道是谁，但你看到巴尼从那个窗户爬进来，然后安保人员。
Like he thinks he made it and then security drags him off.
就像他觉得自己成功了，然后安保人员把他拖走了。
Yeah, there's something.
对，有那么一种。
I don't know how you describe that in the comedy playbook.
我不知道你该怎么在喜剧宝典里描述这个。
Zucker butters.
恶搞。
It's a sucker butters joke.
这是一个恶搞喜剧的笑话。
Yeah, it's, it's, it's, it's airplanes.
对，它是，它是，它是，它是《白头神探》。
Exactly.
没错。
but it's in the foreground, the characters are pretty serious and they're just doing the plot.
但它在前景，角色们都很严肃，他们只是在推进剧情。
And in the background, you see something insane going on, but the audience is supposed to, their eyes are supposed to go to the background.
而在背景中，你看到一些疯狂的事情正在发生，但观众应该，他们的目光应该投向背景。
Nick and Gunn airplane, I would say like that was very, we 100% of the writers room said like, let's do that, let's do our plan.
像《白头神探》里的吉姆·阿布拉姆斯和大卫·扎克，我会说这非常，我们编剧室100%的人都说，我们这么做吧，我们拍我们的计划。
Let's do soccer butters, it's the deep background joke.
我们来做恶搞，这是深景背景笑话。
And yeah, I mean, it's sort of silent comedy.
是的，我的意思是，这有点像无声喜剧。
Is he right, it's a little buster key in almost.
他说得对吗，这几乎有点像巴斯特·基顿。
I love that dorm room scene.
我喜欢那个宿舍房间的场景。
I think it's so sweet, and Jordana was very affected by it.
我觉得它太甜了，乔丹娜对此感触很深。
I thought that lesbian kiss was so sweet, that kiss, but we know when they talk about, I've never had a lesbian kiss, and then Hobie goes in and kisses her.
我以为那个女同之吻太甜了，那个吻，但我们知道当他们谈论时，我从来没有过女同之吻，然后霍比走过去吻了她。
I would have, if we were doing it today, and you asked me, I would have cut the line about field hockey, huh?
如果我们在今天拍这一段，你问我，我会把关于曲棍球的那句台词删掉，对吧？
Yeah, yeah, me too.
对，对，我也是。
I don't think you needed it.
我觉得你不需要它。
I just would have let the kiss be the kiss.
我只会让那个吻就是那个吻。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
Like, there's something so sweet about, like, I'll give you your kiss, you know?
就像，有一种非常甜蜜的感觉，比如，我给你你的吻，你知道吗？
There didn't have to be a comment on it.
没必要对此做任何评价。
The other reason we should go cut that line is that it fought the idea that Robin never played team sports, which she had said to Ted on the roof and slutty pumpkin.
我们应该删掉那句台词的另一个原因是，它与罗宾从未参加过团队运动的设定相冲突，她之前在屋顶上对泰德和欲女南瓜说过这话。
So it was an unneeded treacle cutter, because that was the moment the treacle, the sweet moment could have just stood and also it kind of contradicted something that we had said like in the same season.
所以这是一个不需要的糖蜜切割机，因为那是糖蜜、那个甜蜜的时刻本可以停留的时刻，而且它有点与我们之前说过的一些话相矛盾，比如在同一季里。
So yes, we're gonna go, we'll fix it in post.
所以是的，我们要去，我们会在后期修复它。
We're gonna go cut that right now.
我们现在就去把它剪掉。
This is, what's it, Taylor's versions of her album?
这是，什么来着，泰勒丝专辑的重录版吗？
We're gonna do Josh and Craig's version.
我们要出乔希和克雷格的重录版。
Yeah, we're gonna buy the rights back.
是的，我们要把版权买回来。
We're gonna take out every stupid thing we ever said that offended anybody and also inconsistencies.
我们要删掉我们说过的一切冒犯过任何人的蠢话，还有前后矛盾的地方。
All right, good job.
好了，干得好。
The Alec episode, ladies and gentlemen, the Alec episode.
亚历克特辑，女士们先生们，亚历克特辑。
Great work, Alec.
干得好，亚历克。
This episode is dedicated to our friend Alec Lev.
本集献给我们的朋友亚历克·莱夫。
Well, we're just about at the end of the episode and as ever, we like to start these episodes with a voice note from people letting us know how I met your mother means to them and then we end with a written note from people letting us know the same.
好了，我们差不多到了节目的尾声，和往常一样，我们喜欢在节目开始时播放一段粉丝的语音留言，让他们告诉我们《老爸老妈浪漫史》对他们意味着什么，然后我们以一封书信来结束，同样是让大家告诉我们这些。
If you would like to contribute to this and project, this ongoing project we're doing and maybe have your letter read on the air or your voice note played at the beginning of the show, please go to www.howwemadeyourmotherhwmym.com and go to contact and follow all the instructions we'd be delighted to hear from you.
如果你想为这个项目、这个我们正在进行的长期项目做出贡献，也许想让你的信在节目中被朗读，或者让你的语音留言在节目开头播放，请访问 www.howwemadeyourmotherhwmym.com，点击联系并按照所有说明操作，我们非常高兴听到你的声音。
And today we have a wonderful letter that Craig Thomas is going to read.
今天我们有一封精彩的信，将由克雷格·托马斯来朗读。
Take it away Craig.
交给你了，克雷格。
Yeah, this one is from Apple Podcasts and we're very grateful for anybody that goes on and reviews the show on Apple Podcasts, especially if you say nice things.
是的，这封来自苹果播客，我们非常感谢任何在苹果播客上为节目评分和写评论的人，特别是如果你说了好话的话。
And if you write one, we might read it on the show and it helps the show.
如果你写了一条，我们可能会在节目中朗读它，这有助于节目。
It helps the show grow and it helps us get promoted on there.
这有助于节目的成长，也有助于我们在那里的推广。
So please also get to us this way.
所以请也通过这种方式联系我们。
For example, here's one from Robert W.
例如，这里有一条来自罗伯特·W·
Rogers.
罗杰斯的评论。
The title is exactly what we needed.
标题是：正是我们所需要的。
Great timing as well, so I have high hopes that this will be positive.
时机也很棒，所以我对这个节目充满期待，希望它会是正面的。
This was absolutely grand.
这绝对是太棒了。
I love how formal it starts, Josh.
我喜欢它如此正式的开头，乔希。
This was absolutely grand.
这绝对是太棒了。
It sounds a bit British, maybe.
听起来有点英国风味，也许吧。
Best idea since the show went off the air.
这是该剧停播以来最好的创意。
The best way to relive the sitcom, beginning the end in a new way for repeat viewers.
重温这部情景喜剧的最佳方式，以一种全新的方式为回头客开启结局。
LOL, the behind-the-scenes tidbits and commentary episode by episode.
哈哈，逐集的幕后花絮和评论。
Scenes spoken over entire episodes in a weekly format again that will focus on episodes in order for all 207 episodes.
以每周的形式再次跨越整集进行解说，将按顺序关注全部 207 集。
Yes, so special.
是的，太特别了。
We will try to do all of them for you, by the way.
顺便说一句，我们会尽量为你们制作所有这些内容。
That is our goal.
这就是我们的目标。
It can't be binged or consumed in a weekend, and I can't put away and come back after they've finished, because I'll be returning each week for the latest episode.
它不能在一个周末被一口气看完或消遣掉，我也无法把它放下然后等它们全部完结后再回来，因为我会每周回来收看最新的剧集。
And I love this, because the slow burn over a period is how sitcoms worked.
我喜欢这样，因为这种细水长流的方式正是情景喜剧的运作方式。
Especially these types of shows where there's actual depth and emotional range, expansive storylines evolving over decades, a sitcom.
尤其是这类具有真正深度和情感广度、跨越数十年的宏大故事情节的剧集，一部情景喜剧。
It's still wild to me that a comedic sitcom managed to become so much more than that, and they succeeded far beyond.
对我来说，一部喜剧情景喜剧能发展成为远超于此的作品，并且取得了远超预期的成功，这依然让我感到不可思议。
Well, thank you.
好吧，谢谢。
Friends had its moments.
《老友记》也有它的高光时刻。
Now we're going, I'm nervous.
现在我们要，我开始紧张了。
Like, is it going to compare us to friends?
比如，它会拿我们和《老友记》作比较吗？
Okay, I'm just going to power through.
好吧，我只能硬着头皮坚持下去了。
Friends had its moments.
《老友记》也有它的高光时刻。
It had some sad scenes, deeper stories, flashbacks, true character depth, yes.
它有一些悲伤的场景、更深层次的故事、倒叙，真正的角色深度，是的。
But Hymnium went to new level with it and managed to get it right, despite flashbacks and jumping scenes, all episode long, all series long.
但《老爸老妈浪漫史》将其提升到了一个新的水平，并且设法做到了这一点，尽管整集、整部剧都穿插着倒叙和场景跳跃。
But they did it and it worked.
但他们做到了，而且效果很好。
And the ability to intrigue, keep mystery, questions open, lasting six, seven years, a half-hour sitcom managed to be and do all of that.
而且能够保持悬念、保持神秘感、留下未解的疑问，持续了六、七年，一部半小时的情景喜剧设法做到了这一切。
Despite being the real classical type sitcom, the friend-sign followed Cheers-style comedic show.
尽管它是一部真正的传统经典情景喜剧，带有《老友记》和《欢乐酒店》风格的喜剧表现形式。
It fit that precisely, but also in its own way.
它完美地契合了这一点，但同时也拥有自己独特的风格。
Same way friends brought its own vibe to the classic style in the 1990s.
就像《老友记》在20世纪90年代为经典风格注入了独特的氛围一样。
Himyum did a modern spin, but it was every bit the traditional broadcast prime-time networks sitcom, and so much more.
《老爸老妈浪漫史》进行了现代化的演绎，但它完全是一部传统的电视台黄金时段情景喜剧，甚至远不止于此。
So there's a lot to unpack and dig into, and since much of the staff, not to mention the crew, creators, and writers, do very little presser interviews, do we do some stuff?
所以有很多内容需要剖析和深入挖掘，既然许多幕后工作人员，更不用说剧组、主创和编剧们，很少接受记者采访，那我们要不要做点什么？
Come on.
来吧。
The Deep Talk and Reflection over the show never really happened, but it's now off the air for just over 10 years.
对这部剧的深度探讨和反思其实从未真正进行过，但现在它已经停播十多年了。
It's a fantastic time to do this.
现在做这件事是个绝佳的时机。
Plenty of post premium life, reflection, introspection, experiences amongst cast and crew.
剧组主创人员在剧集完结后的生活中，有着充足的反思、内省和各种经历。
Getting their recollection and tidbits from the other side of the show is fascinating.
从这部剧的另一面了解他们的回忆和花絮，实在太迷人了。
So I'm game.
所以我奉陪到底。
I'm here for it and I'll be here till all 207 plus episodes are dropped here.
我全力支持，而且我会一直守在这里，直到全部207集以上的节目全部上线。
Thank you, Robert.
谢谢你，罗伯特。
That is a lovely message and we appreciate the reveal on Apple Podcasts.
这是一条非常棒的留言，我们很感激你在苹果播客上的公开支持。
Keep them coming y'all.
大家继续发呀。
Yeah.
是的。
Thanks everyone.
谢谢大家。
See you next time.
下次见。
How We Made Your Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thompson.
《老爸老妈浪漫史》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
本节目由我亚历克·莱夫制作，我们的联合制作人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios and our digital content producer AKA Gen Z Master is Emily Blumberg.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是蓝色点工作室的亚历克斯·里夫斯，我们的数字内容制作人兼Z世代大师是艾米莉·布隆伯格。
Artwork by John Morrow.
封面艺术由约翰·莫罗创作。
Please follow, rate and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评价和评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这真的对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是由乔什·拉德纳本人创作的《纽约市》，附加音乐由克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基创作。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢劳拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to sign up for our Substack mailing list and for links to our social media.
访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 注册我们的 Substack 邮件列表，并获取我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以点击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是本节目的重要组成部分。
Want some merch?
想要一些周边商品吗？
Click on the store link or go to HowYouGetYourMerch.com.
点击商店链接或访问 HowYouGetYourMerch.com。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack, order Craig Thomas' debut novel at CraigThomasWriter.com slash novel, and you could subscribe to my Dead Father's Society also on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳的 Muse Letters，在 CraigThomasWriter.com/novel 上订购克雷格·托马斯的首部小说，你还可以在 Substack 上订阅我的《已故父亲协会》。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital heart disease research.
要了解如何为本节目持续开展的旨在为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的公益活动贡献力量。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”标签页。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures.
本集节目得到了 Backyard Ventures 的大力支持。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞的。